hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
what's going on how I I am once again
this is like all of a sudden I never
have [ __ ] guests and then all of a
sudden they all come out of the woodwork
almost at the same time on all musicians
and once again we have a very special
guest miss tal Wilkenfeld how are you
I'm good
you got a new album coming out yep right
just glad you know I day I didn't want
to start with that because I know you
[ __ ] been talking about all kinds of
music I had to ask you because we're
over your place right now well how you
liking the Vitamix I love the Vitamix
cuz I gotten into like I'm an old man
now I don't know if you can tell I use a
lot of lotion I think I'm still in my
20s but I'm but to turn 51 here in June
and I've started to do like for
breakfast
I like to just have like a smoothie yeah
as phony as that sounds to everybody
doesn't live in it's the [ __ ]
greatest thing ever right you just drink
it you're full yeah you know rather than
doing the Denny's Grand Slam breakfast
you feel like a tub of [ __ ] which makes
you eat something else bad so people
been telling me about the Vitamix my
life ready I'm like like that was the
thing you have all these amazing
instruments and [ __ ] and the thing that
stuck I was like oh a Vitamix I wonder
if that one Masha's up the [ __ ]
spinach and kale a little bit better I
have the best recipe - you do yes I got
two really good ones that I stand by
they trade I got one that I substitute
the kale for spinach spinach tastes
better all it is it's just that
substitute dandelion greens just FYI you
swiff I use dandelion greens now what do
you do to sweeten that up so it's not
bitter as [ __ ] I use some honey just a
little bit just a little bit
ya know one time my wife took me to some
restaurant we ended up eating like
dandelions like a dandelion we both
trying it out like hey man let's be
healthy we both looked at each other
it's like it was one of the worst things
I ever tasted so when you grind that up
what do you have almond milk in there
too or it's it's actually a juice really
it's not like a smoothie but it's quite
thick which is why I still call it a
smoothie but - dandelion greens cilantro
a little bit of black pepper oh my god
tumeric
ginger like fresh gin or what you call
me okay what you stand by that it's the
song sing it sounds a little bit of
honey what else do I put in there water
there's obviously water and and then I
get hungry an hour and a half later
where do you buy do Danny's going your
backyard and you come out of the [ __ ]
grass what do you get your dandelions
like any health food store home food sir
I never say I gotta be honest with you
now I've been to a few of those little
health food places I've never I've never
seen that but uh
all right mind mine's just simple it's
just a almond it's a almond milk with
some almonds just in case it's not
enough almond in there that's some
spinach the [ __ ] is a banana a little
bit of ice I know I'm forgetting
something
berries blueberries no I got to get a
couple coats cuz I I basically have to
go to smoothies and I'm getting sick of
them and then I have like this Greek
yogurt parfait and I just sort of rotate
that on a three thin I'm just I've had
it you know you know like when you've
been jamming with people too long you're
like we need some new blood or something
that's where I am with mustn't me trying
to steer it back to the music here so
let's at least say the name of your
incredible album that I only heard three
tracks of because I couldn't figure out
how to download it for those of you not
familiar with Tala she's she's basically
played with everybody and I promised her
I wasn't gonna bring up all the past
like hey man what was it like playing
with this person but she's you know IMDB
or she's played with literally everybody
and you've basically been known as this
monster bass player that can just play
with anybody and your hidden talent of
an unbelievable singing voice is finally
displayed like that's what killed me
when I listened he just played those
three tracks for me aside from of course
how upfront you know the basses and all
the mix which I'm loving yeah I had no
idea you could sing like that I kind of
um I I've kept it quiet for a while like
I started as a singer-songwriter when I
first picked up guitar mm-hmm and then
sort of started focusing just on guitar
when I moved to America as I left home
when I was 16 right I moved to America
and I went to this music school for a
little while and I went from like only
being hope you went to a nice place all
this crap about the Michael Jackson
documentary which I
used to [ __ ] watch why would you do
that why would you put although that
those horrible stories in your head it's
like I get it all right the guy was a
creep and now he's dead so what are we
doing I guess you got a list somebody's
going someone was telling me going you
how well you have to watch it so then
you you as a parent it's like I'm not
gonna let some [ __ ] guys sleep with
my kid behind nine doors anyway so you
got this album I went to this this
school and I went from being allowed to
play like half an hour a day to wanting
to practice for like six hours a day was
that torture for you considering the way
you took I remember you here yeah I
watched that interview you said the
first time you actually played a chord
you got emotional you cried yeah so you
love something that much and then all of
a sudden you're going to you go into
school in Australia yeah so they were
teaching about Columbus and all the
great stuff that happened here in
America of course right
whatever it was how you guys you got
dropped off by the English convicts
apparently yeah exactly
yeah exactly so then all of a sudden was
that torture for you in school it was
just it was hard because you know
academia was the focus especially like
where I like with who I grew up with you
know my mom just like really wanted me
to you know to imagine yeah I do all my
schoolwork and stuff I mean she's
probably just being a responsible parent
but like I just was not into geography
and history I was into did you ever just
like pick up the bass and be like mom
listen to this I mean listen to this and
then look at my grades in math and you
tell me which direction I'm supposed to
go in I mean I was just I was a
guitarist at that point like I only
switched to bass when I was 17 which and
I already moved to America at that point
but yeah I mean she heard me play I just
I think that like you know the music
business is a tough place and she
probably just thought like maybe maybe
that's not the best thing for you to do
to be in the music industry it's so
uncertain so but I wasn't gonna listen
to what anyone was gonna say like that's
all I knew that I had to be a musician
and I didn't
care if I was gonna be homeless and
write and be a musician I just I knew
that that's what I had to do so I no
wonder how many how many musicians are
out there because that story is like you
had that inner drive and like I always
wanted like how many like Jimi Hendrix
there was like working at Home Depot
because their parents or some something
you know they just didn't have that
thing to be like no no no [ __ ] that I'm
doing it right when really important
people that basically taught you how to
walk and talk and all of that stuff
start telling you you know you shouldn't
go in that direction is that's just
something that you it was that something
that developed was it the love that you
had when you started playing guitar that
you were like no I literally have to do
this or do you feel you always had sort
of that that that drive well I actually
think as a kid especially as a teenager
like if your parents tell you not to do
something you're gonna want to do it
more like 99% of teenagers I'd read
those days so it probably worked out in
the the right way that she didn't really
want me to focus on music because that
just made me want to do it more oh okay
yeah I mean I'm kind of I mean I
wouldn't even say I was necessarily
rebellious but if you want something
that bad and someone's telling you know
you're like well I'll prove to you that
I really deserve this and I'm gonna work
my ass off and I did like I was so
focused like my rebellion as a teenager
was to succeed as a musician it wasn't
like to go off and do drugs or whatever
else like that was my rebellion was was
success you know I went to I was looking
at schools to see which one to take you
know put my daughter and you know all
the public schools a [ __ ] out here I
guess so you gotta send him to private
school and spend like a zillion dollars
by the time they're like eight it's so
[ __ ] stupid so he went to this one
and it was like a french-speaking one
right and so all the kids was amazing
the kids were super smart great school
and and but the lady given like the tour
right she goes the hell did she say I
asked her I said hey you know they're
the parents kind of learned French along
the way she's like no we encourage you
to speaks it perfect English at home and
blah blah I said what
I wanna learn to and she looked at me
she goes yes it's too late for you just
like goddamn I actually respected it but
you know what I'm so happy she said that
to me because now I got this thing like
I'll show you
yeah and I got flashcards I would have
flashcards and I'm like looking at I'm
trying to put together phrases and stuff
I you know listen the back of my head I
know she's probably right and I love the
school that I'm actually excited that
the potential to go there but like I I
do relate to that as far as when
somebody says that but there was a
period in my life where I wasn't that
guy oh yeah like if somebody said that
to me I'd be like oh okay forget it
oh really so I think I've probably had
that since I was really young like like
just determination to do whatever I want
to do cuz like I remember being super
focused on running before I was a guitar
player and I was like obsessed with
long-distance running like and and in my
head I'm like I have to be the best I
have to be the best runner goals one
girl that was better than me and and it
pissed me off so much and I remember
like there was this one race that was I
don't know it's like a ten mile race it
was really long and and I just I just
had to beat this girl and I did beat the
girl who do but I did this like like
celebratory dance afterwards because I
was so excited and I threw my back out
then I I kind of was like humbling
around for a little while and couldn't
run like a couple weeks and then that's
actually when I walked past that guitar
and insided play everything she saw it
she was that far behind me wow that's
like a feel-good movie except dated they
always run krytus before you blow out
your back then you became like your
musician so you know the few tracks that
I heard in that three the three that I
listened to is definitely you know this
is really like a very personal album as
far as like you know talking about
yourself that one you just play what was
the name of the haunted heart wanted
love haunted love the one that's just
the bass and voice the orchestra yeah
yeah that was some pretty heavy lyrics
that maybe you start thinking about my
parents
I went on a little trip there well yeah
yeah thinking about my whole life and I
people listening here I can't recommend
like the level of quality of the music
that you you've done with other people
and now to actually hear hey these are
my ideas with your voice on top of it
the second I heard a few of these I was
like oh this is one of these these
albums I'm just gonna put in back in
that day when you had a CD just stick it
in there until the thing just started
skipping on it what you mean how your
iTunes the skipping on you right now
like 30 seconds I know I I'm the worst
oh you can download it you gots
Modifieds I don't have Spotify I I'm I'm
this idiot I still buy music and then it
fills up your computer and now because
right now I need a new I need a new
laptop I need a new phone and I know I
play iPad the whole thing [ __ ] in the
bed on me at the same time and yeah I
miss can i buy it on vinyl I have a
record player already got me a burrito
here from coming over so I'll throw some
money towards that but I was gonna say
so you also mentioned that you're
actually gonna be doing a whole tour in
this thing too huh yeah now a headlining
tour you open and we're headlining
headlining nice I'm excited Boston it's
just your first like big headlining tour
cuz you've always been like the hired
gun as far as I know yeah this is your
first like um well I I actually I was
opening for the WHO with my band and we
played the Boston Garden and something
really cool is it called the Boston
Garden
ah they called the TD Banknorth Garden
keed
how'd you like that that was fun didn't
you do that recently yeah I did some
stand-up there yeah and I did jam before
with my brother so cool we had a good
way out we definitely had your you know
it's so funny whoo yeah ever no one was
paying attention at all we were playing
or whatever they thought was kind of
funny that we're doing it and this is
comedian Jim Breuer who does this
amazing bit on Slayer fans like how
dedicated and crazy they are well we
actually play it I forget what song we
play you played his Slayer song and
literally this it was like no one was
reacting to anything we were doing we
sucked right the second we started
playing Slayer some [ __ ] security
guide like you know halfway if the arena
just goes
hilarious so now your style of music
like going no you can ask me something I
was gonna say like like what does
playing before a stand-up set do for you
it makes the venue not as intimidating
I've only done it it like why why it is
because you know it stand up in a place
that big doesn't make sense you like
honey you know I I had all these
feelings of like why am I like how did I
get here what am I doing here what the
[ __ ] do I have to say that justifies all
these people showing up you know they're
normal if you're any sort of like human
being that's what you have if you're a
psychopath you just like how come I'm
not playing the football playing the
Roman Colosseum but I yeah I was sitting
there and that's what that was what was
going through my head but the first time
I ever did one I did for the New York
Comedy Festival and I did Madison Square
Garden and we got together and jammed in
there and I just did that because I
loved Led Zeppelin and they did song
remains the same if I could just play
some drums there and make a little bit
of noise and what happened was we were
having so much fun and I invited so many
people down there they like you know I
didn't ever fully forget where I was but
next thing you know you know I was
yelling hey Josh is it that Motley Crue
thing and you just yelling and you just
kind of made it yours yeah so that night
it just didn't it didn't feel I was able
to kind of just like I had already made
a bunch of noise in there and nothing
bad happened you know I didn't know the
roof didn't collapse so I think that
that's kind of like what it did for me
although I [ __ ] up at the forum
because I played it like three hours I
almost [ __ ] up because I was just like
I got off stage and I was like wiped out
I was just like oh I know oh no but then
like the Adrenaline's like oh my god
what if I vomit from all these [ __ ]
people you know that that'll get you
through a good 90-minute why do you not
like play on stage for your audience
because I respect them you say that I'm
good for a comedian I'll give you that
but I am NOT a you know what I like
like one of my favorite things to do is
to watch a pro play mm-hmm cuz it's just
you know when they're just doing like a
soundcheck a lot of times they'll be
physically playing something that I
could play but I could never make it
sound like that and there's always like
a personnel you know if you listen to a
really good drummer you can hear like
you can hear them in the playing which
you know took me a while to be able to
hear that but now I'm able to do and
I've seen I don't know there's just
something cool about it it's like
watching a professional hockey player
like taping up this stick this is just
something that when you see a pro doing
something it's in you're into it
especially if it's your hobby it's
[ __ ] mesmerizing so that's that's why
when a few times I've come over here
like I'm always in there because I like
sitting back and just watching all you
guys play and my favorite thing about
watching a live band is watching a band
that doesn't play it the same way every
night and even if you've never seen the
band you can tell because they're like
looking at each other and everything so
that's when I get into like oh man
they're in the moment right now this is
like watching a comic Griff and
somebody's gonna do something to make
somebody smile and then they add
something else tonight and just as an
audience member and a fan of music
trying to pick up like that thing going
on and like my intern like I'm the
band's I listened to growing up like I
remember Stevie Ray Vaughan whenever he
was playing a solo it was like Chris
Layton and Tommy Shannon and Reese were
always looking right at him like is he
gonna go back in again oh we go we going
back to you know him singing and he just
would [ __ ] be wailing it and he had
this little thing you just look at him
he gives him a little nod and how they
all were like okay and and and they
wouldn't [ __ ] that up I'm just having
attempted to you know get together with
friends and play and everything I just I
have such an admiration for it so I mean
that's how I feel about comedy and great
comedy and that's why I like watching
you perform oh yeah when I do a great
[ __ ] joke and I'm not over to somebody
who just did a dick joke janitor
it's right on the same level no but like
cuz I just started as you know like
getting it really heavily into comedy
the past like a year or so yeah and like
the reason that appeals to me so much is
because it like speaks to both parts of
me as a musician there's the the jazz
musician in me which is like the
improvisational musician which like like
really enjoys watching you riff like in
wrong just and then there's lash bomb
then there's like the composer like the
the person that's like you know into
writing songs and like and then watching
you create this amazing material pilots
it's very sad it's not a requirement for
people in your band because I mean when
you work when you go and do this tour
like I I just know doing the same jokes
over and over and over again it's like
you have to like yeah do something to
break out of it do you on this tour I
mean you sell any album you got to go
out and and and you know play it and
sell the music to them like how how much
like messing around do you do I do a lot
and then is a requirement and that's why
it's been really tricky to find band
members and I have found like the
perfect guitarist and drummer to play
with me because you know my music is
compositionally like lyrically for
instance very influenced by folk music
or just songwriter music but then
musically it's it's influenced from
anything from rock to folk to jazz to
whatever it just goes all over the place
that's what I was loving but this this
some sort of through line maybe it's you
I don't know what it is on and because I
was just listening to dance sound is so
great and then I I really started
listening to the mix of it I'm like wow
she's the whole bottom end of this song
and then it felt I don't how to say
technically but it felt like the guitars
and keys were like up here yeah and but
you were the sort of the meat and
potatoes of the whole thing driving the
whole song but like the the different
tones and stuff there was why I'm worst
I don't know the names of the corner
page you're the first one yeah when you
went into that bridge it was ours out
though it's sections called that middle
sections just like what the [ __ ] is that
and then you go right
back to that part that really rocks oh
yeah because when I looked at you I was
just like that's when the crowds gonna
go nuts cuz you taking him on this ride
where you coming out and you just you
know blowing their wig back in the
beginning and then it goes to this other
places like whoa what the [ __ ] is this
this is this mood thing well that's what
it's like hey people start taking their
drugs in the crowd I would feel that was
a time off since somebody sparked up a
[ __ ] J's we used to say and and then
all of a sudden like I don't know where
you just punch him in the face again and
then the [ __ ] song is over it's just
like yeah I think that the cohesiveness
on the record comes from like having the
same band play all of these songs even
though they're they're very different
like some are you know just vocal and
bass and some are acoustic guitar and
and very little behind me and then
there's like these full rockers but it's
the same band and I just think that
that's really important like first laws
it take you to put that together well it
took me a few years to sort of search
for the sound of the record right and
like figure out who was gonna play on it
and who like what was the the the best
sound for these songs and then I finally
went into the studio with Blake Mills
and Jeremy and Paul Stacey and we cut
corner painter which is the first song I
played you and it's the first song on
the record and that when I heard that
back on the speakers and this was no
bass it was just I was playing acoustic
baritone guitar Blake was playing guitar
and Jeremy was playing drums and the
sound was so full well I think I didn't
even want to play bass on it
there's no bass on that song at all I
just played it on an organ and then
Benmont Tench overdubbed organ as well
like a pump organ mm-hmm but I heard
that song was like this is the lynchpin
for the record and so then I went home
and I like wrote a bunch of other songs
that I felt would fit with that vibe or
complement it and and then once I'd done
that we went back in the studio for it
was like anywhere from like 8 to 10 days
and cut the whole thing at once Wow and
so I think that that's part of the the
cohesiveness is that we just we cut it
all together hey when you've put
together a band if you
had been like okay I know these two
people are right and then a third person
comes in and so takes it into another
direction you got to fire one of those
other two people there just because but
the other cuz the other person's such a
beast I mean it's a it's all about can
notice I pointed at the drums when I
said fake casting for a movie to like
sometimes it's the most important thing
is the casting all right how do you like
LA by the way miss Australia I don't
miss Australia some of my best friends
are there I definitely missed them you
know but and I miss the beach I don't
really think that the beach in LA is
that cool no I got me I'm terrified of
the ocean and but every time I go to
Australia it's like oh if I was ever you
know there's a place to get eaten by a
shark it's definitely the coast of your
country it's so beautiful I was you know
at least you die beautifully yeah no I I
remember we were there and like I don't
know when we were it was your your weird
winter down there which is just a
different time and it was too it was too
cold and windy it's not weird it's just
weird to me cuz I'm in the northern
hemisphere but it so we were down there
and I was expecting it to be [ __ ] hot
and all of a sudden was like freezin and
but even then I was looking at I was
like if it wasn't so rough and it wasn't
so cold I think I would and maybe I did
actually go into the water when I was in
Perth because I just wanted to say that
I stood in the Indian Ocean I literally
went up to my ankles and I got back in
and then I got in the car and I was
listening to the radio and there was a
helicopter following it like an 18 foot
tiger shark along the beach just to let
the surfers and everybody know that the
thing was there and you guys had the
creepiest terminology ever for when
someone gets eaten by a shark you say he
was taken that's what I heard oh yeah
yeah I was some blow like he got taken
I'm like oh my god I'd rather be eaten
than taken eating to me is it's over I
mean it's [ __ ] horrific and then I
you bleed out and it's overtaking means
I you took me somewhere I just start
thinking a Chain Saw Massacre when that
[ __ ] guy just grabbed that woman and
yanked her and slam the door taking all
my sounds slightly more polite though
now you can
well I guess what the next word is taken
to the movies right exactly to the
movies shocks oh yeah I was gonna say
you know it seems you know what I liked
it's this fair play on this album yeah
as far as there was a few where it was
the other person that was a few there
was you right so that's a that's a
that's an important milestone in your
life when you at least for me it was
when I was able to be like I you know I
was going through chicks of [ __ ]
psychos you know I did that tall I was
about 35 and I was just like I fell you
know at what point are you gonna [ __ ]
is it maybe you maybe who you're picking
maybe what you're bringing to the table
and then once I was able to do that I am
finally ended up meeting Nia I that's
kind of why I called the album love
remains because love remains as in the
remnants of love like the aftermath of
her love gone bad
or love remains like love still exists
oh oh I thought you meant there was
still pieces of other relationships in
you it it's both it's like the remnants
and then love still you know continues
there's always love well this is theory
among my guy friends that women are able
to cry it out because you're allowed to
cry that you're able to get past [ __ ]
and then it's just like [ __ ] gone
where guys like hang on to [ __ ]
I mean I was reading this book on Bob
Cousy he's one of the great Celtics and
Bill Russell right one of the greatest
players of all time
and Bob koozies wife passed away and he
still has a picture on the wall and he
still talks to all I guess I didn't
break up so maybe it was that but like
you know I still always joke with my
wife going you know if I'd died within
three weeks she'd have all my clothes
down a good will keep maybe a DVD in the
back of a [ __ ] closet but she's like
no I would never do that but I just feel
like women are better at you know how
you're wired and then I also think it's
more it's one of the great emotions
crying when the great healing emotions
is not a
acceptable for guys and you just shut it
off so not only do not get to heal you
actually make yourself I think worse by
[ __ ] holding it in it's bad enough
you know I don't know it's it's a really
weird thing so that's that's actually I
don't I don't know what the word is but
to hear you say that that you actually
some of it stays in there I don't know
that makes me feel not as [ __ ] up yeah
also like I feel like when when you're
in love or when you love someone like in
people often like projected outwards as
if it's the other person that's making
you in love whereas like love is
actually just always in you and that
that person is maybe igniting it or
showing you that it's there but it is
always there and knowing that keeps me
centered yeah it's it's it's that's not
something that you can it's hard to
remember that you know I would I would
say I don't know I'm actually literally
getting uncomfortable just even talking
about it it helps my was walled off for
a long [ __ ] time and then I had like
this massive amount of love in me and it
would just come out in these weird ways
like about like like animals being
abused or any sort of person being hurt
I could feel it but like if I was just
with somebody and we're going to the
movies like I didn't even know what the
[ __ ] to do I'd just be sitting there
like this [ __ ] robot like did you
enjoy that
now we're getting on the subway and it
was just like and I was meeting people I
just I mean I I'm embarrassed that we're
the kind of person I was back in the day
as far as like trying to get through
stuff like that but how did you break
through that I met somebody I couldn't
break up with him I would in my head
fantasize during tough times of breaking
up with my now wife and in my head we
were living in this place where there
was there was first place was an
elevated another place had stairs and
when she was going to get on the
elevator even in the fantasy of being
single again before the door closed I
would run out and go get her or when she
would walk down the stairs and all right
I come
I couldn't I couldn't even and for years
I did that and it never dawned on me
like I've always been so [ __ ] like
not in touched with like hey Bill you
know this is the 20,000th [ __ ] signal
like I used to ride around had a paper
route back in the day and I used to ride
around in the morning and I had
memorized comedy routines with my
favorite comedians and I would fantasize
that I was doing them in front of the
school and it didn't dawn on me at that
point they hate bill maybe you want to
be a comedian it didn't it was just yeah
I had no connection to it whatsoever huh
it was just me I think at that point it
was all about you know getting people to
like me so I wouldn't get the [ __ ]
kicked out of me or I wouldn't have to
deal with some you know you know was you
know it was it was before all this
caring on social media is just like you
know the hope every day at school is
just like am I gonna get it today or how
can I get it off for me and get it on to
the next weakest kid it was a very weird
I don't know some of it was good but a
lot of it wasn't necessarily probably
the way kids should grow up now we're
probably like overly doing it I don't
know you don't made me feel good when
you can't when I came into your place
there and you were like oh there's my
phone oh my gosh you have massive a DD
i-- i also unfortunately get phone
anxiety which I hate lectures oh you
don't have it right yeah if I don't have
it I start to like feel like oh [ __ ]
where's the phone or like if I don't
look at it for for too long I start to
feel that and so I have to work really
hard at like disciplining myself so that
I can like keep it away from me for a
certain amount of hours to be like
creative and productive because it's
just I feel so sorry for like for kids
that are like teenagers right now like
they're just like so attached to their
phones and I see what it does to my
brain teenager I am that's brutal
ya know it like gives you the shortest
attention span it like everything's just
immediate and so I'm just so glad that
like it kind of came a little bit later
you realize we're like
brats because we're like sort of the
first wave of like well let's see what
this does to people I actually saw you
know I went and I got gas today and I
saw this after the burrito I know oh
that's gonna be later that's why this
podcast will not be a full hour whenever
they you know it's hitting me what the
[ __ ] is on the microphones that I hear
that me nuts piece of fuzz it's still
there see this is the podcast people are
used to get them so I pulled up to get
yeah I was getting pumping gas and you
know this la couple pulls up la meaning
beautiful I'm not judging them like
they're [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
beautiful right so they pull up and the
guy gets out the pump the gas the
woman's driving the second she barely
pressed park you know the immediately
the phone and was just sitting there and
I was watching her and I was just like
that's me that is literally me I do that
when I'm driving like a lot I know it's
it's it's yeah I called a friend up one
time this is maybe about three months
ago I was trying to do like an intense
period of writing and I said hey could
you just because I'm you know it takes I
think apparently 28 days to break a
habit I think you come over for you know
of 28 days apparently
can I give you my phone and then just go
away and then I'll meet you back here
and I did that for a few days and
actually like helped me like reprogram
my cell yeah yeah and like once you do
that then it's like ah you feel like you
can finally relax it's weird this is
something that I learned going overseas
and I can't get texts or anybody this is
what happens if you don't text anybody
nobody texts you like I would come back
thinking oh my god I haven't checked my
text messages in 10 days I'm gonna have
5 million [ __ ] texts and I had like
maybe six really seven yeah what am ia
loser nobody like it's like I don't text
people you're like no I come back to a
zillion of them now I feel like an
[ __ ] no I came back and it's just
like you it's it's like you know like
once you want something in your life not
to happen and you don't realize how much
of it you're creating yeah okay well so
much of the phone [ __ ] I realize I am
creating all of the texting that I'm
doing like I'm in traffic traffic sucks
I just start call
and people right it's like hey man
what's going on in the [ __ ] I literally
have a friend of mine that we like we
are friendship because she's married
with kids I'm married and have a kid and
it's just like our whole relationship I
don't think I've seen her in a year and
a half our relationship that we have the
deal the unwritten deal is that we call
each other when we're stuck in traffic
yeah
then the big joke is a I'm on the 134
right yep and that's in or the other
person picks up all right where are you
how long a drive do you have and it's
just like you're sort of almost like a
suicide hotline I getting them to get
home I do like all of my phone calls in
the car - or really really late at night
like while I'm getting ready for bed
like like my friends in Australia just
know that I'm gonna call like 3:00 a.m.
my time like facetiming them while I'm
like brushing my teeth and [ __ ] and now
it's like a ritual like oh we ready for
teeth brushing times huh
and what is it like 7:00 the next day
they're right 7:00 at night 40 or even
slightly yeah something like that yeah
right around about then it's great that
guy I always call Australia at that time
when I'm getting ready for bed it was
time it was the last time you heard some
music that made you like whenever I
listen to like amazing music I always
fantasize that it's me doing it oh yeah
yeah I do that no run all the way
through the song if the drums are
awesome I'm playing drums someone's
singing great then all of a sudden I'm
doing that I'm very self-involved when
was the last time you as a musician
listen to something and you were just
like oh [ __ ] I wish that was me does
that happen
all right no it doesn't happen but
strike two with the texting and now
you're fantasizing I don't do that but I
listen and admire a lot of people hold
you - listen - coming up I didn't want
to ask you any of these questions I know
you Vanessa listen to Miles Davis and
then of course there was the Bee Gees
jazz disco I just you know what I'm
really obsessed with is Indian classical
music do you remember that time we were
like driving back from one of your shows
and I played you some Indian Indian
classical music I play Bob Dylan song to
you which he really didn't like or you
were making fun
but Bob Dylan is like one of my
favorites of all time I love Bob doing
okay but like you were like joking
around like changing the lyrics and
stuff I was just being an [ __ ]
we do that all the time you made me
laugh so much and then I played you an
Indian classical piece but maybe you
don't remember that but what I know I
remember you played me that blues song
yeah that was Blind Willie Johnson yes
also one of my favs yes okay yeah dad I
remember yeah I love old blues like it's
so raw and real right and I also like
like is if you you'll notice like on my
album like I switch in and out of like
time signatures a lot and but it doesn't
sound like I'm switching time CP inches
at least that's what I do that all the
things that I yeah I didn't really
notice it but that's what I'm saying
like because I kind of I let the music
like the melody or the story guide the
time as opposed to like the other way
around like a sometimes people will
write the music first and then that lay
the melody and stuff on top I saw an
interview with somebody said that said
every time I come on with the riff it's
in a weird time signature and then the
drummer fixes it I remember thinking
like these should have [ __ ] kept it
right
getting that yeah but like why not what
I'm just saying that so that's what I
that's what I would think yeah I was
joking around like with with Bob Weir
because like basically he played with
lightning hopping medium Bob Weir yeah
mm-hmm
Grateful Dead right he played with
lightnin Hopkins who's one of my
favorite like blues players and I know
when he started like those guys were all
like in their 40s right yeah Edie Lou's
guys I mean and and he was joking around
like saying that like lightning plate
like the twelve-and-a-half Bob loose
because you know if he has to add a beat
to finish the the story he's telling
there's gonna add a beat like it's not
about like just this rigid thing and
like I was I've been composing like that
too like if the melody wants to go on a
few beats longer or you know then make
it a bar or seven like and it will feel
natural if if it goes with the melody
but if you try to fit a melody over the
top of the time signature then sometimes
it can feel a little bit more choppy
yeah oh I get that now because then it's
because to the layperson they're not
listening what time it's in no they
doing
melody and the story is the same if I
call that old folk music to like you
listen to some old folk like you hear
like Baz of five and seven because
they're just adding beats to like finish
the phrase yeah I know I never noticed
and that's sometimes why like you know
that there won't be drums on it like if
there was drums it probably would sound
kind of strange but it's just like an
acoustic guitar in a voice like that
song I played for you that Bob Dylan
song it's called it's a right mom and he
bleeding like this emboss of like five
and [ __ ] in that he just like adds some
beats and you wouldn't you wouldn't know
it but if you counted it it's odd
because he's just trying to fit the
lyric in oh yeah it's it's genius I love
it you're so talented in that area like
when did when did you notice that [ __ ]
like I would just be like I'm just
psyched if I listened to a song I know
all the words oh that was just in seven
when I first like moved to America and I
was playing guitar I and I was like
starting to play like six hours a day
and I like gave myself tendinitis and I
had to stop playing for a minute and
then I started like like messing around
like with drums with one hand or like
bass with one hand and people started
coming up to me being like yeah mini
Vinnie Vinnie Vinnie
and I'm like what the [ __ ] is mini
Vinnie like you know Vinnie Colaiuta
okay so I went and like listened to
Vinnie Colaiuta this was me at I guess
like 17 now and and everyone was passing
around tapes of Vinnie Colaiuta like
well like the stuff with charisma and
stuff and and actually Vinnie was then
one of the first people I met when when
I moved to America because he came to my
school and I'd been playing for two and
a half months at the time and like one
of the these drum clinicians was friends
with him wait a minute you would only
been playing two and a half months and
somebody told you to move to a space
because I've been playing guitar for a
couple years
yeah yeah right what was that like and
he was like oh we should play sometime I
said yeah and I was so shy like because
I'd listened to all this stuff and
obviously his he's one of the best in
the world and I was but I kept it in my
head I'm like okay okay
then I moved to New York and I like I
just want to be a jazz musician I want
to like play in clubs like five times a
night and like Charlie Parker and monk
and all the guys did right and and I did
that for a few years and then that's
when I like I played with the Allman
Brothers and like made a record played
with the Allman Brothers that was my
first gig when I was a teenager Jesus
Christ yeah like that's where it all
started and then I came back to LA and I
like played Vanitas stuff with the oume
Brothers in my my solo project and and
then the weeks later he got the call
from Jeff Beck that like or hit Jeff
Beck's management that they needed a
bass player and then he he told them
about me and then they called me and
they asked me to send in tapes I sent in
the tapes and the next thing I knew I
was flying to England to audition for
Jeff so and then everything like you
know Prince and her gone how are you I
think I was 21 when I started playing
with Jeff yeah that's the first time I
saw you we're talking that live at
Ronnie Scott's which I've still never
been in there the couple times I've gone
to London I already see it it's always
like packed I'm like I'll [ __ ] want
to go in there and just yeah have a
drink and actually listen to some music
for like two so that's the first time I
saw you so were you nervous when you
went into the audition well I was food
poisoned I just got enough a plane like
where me and Vinny went to the airport
and I ate some barbecue chicken pizza
and I got on the plane and Vinny's like
raving on about politics because he's
obsessed with politics and I'm like eh
Vinny I'm feeling kind of sick and he's
like yeah yeah so then this happened and
that yeah I mean he kind of reminds me
of you and you write me of him I thought
he was from he's from like Pennsylvania
Oh is he yeah yeah yeah Pittsburgh
always some Pittsburgh yeah it's a
Pittsburgh guy
oh you went to Berkeley that's why I
knew there was some sort of
Massachusetts right right there okay
yeah but anyway he's going on about
politics and then meanwhile I just like
throw up in a bag and I'm like there it
is you think that what is I'm like I'll
see you in ten hours and I was so sick
that like then I had to like get rushed
to the hospital only
and like beyond a drip and then the next
day I auditioned for Jeff and so I was
feeling really weird but talk about the
worst [ __ ] place to give food poison
went well because at that point I was so
like woozy that I was just like okay
let's get through this and and then that
was the point where like Jeff pointed to
me and said so low on cause we've ended
his lovers and like he ended up loving
that so much that he like kept it in the
set and that's how he was like featuring
me every night oh wow that's which is so
like cool of him
considering who he is and all of that
stuff too like I love when people do
stuff like that there's a lot of
comedians that I you know that I'm a fan
of but what really makes me you know
over the top is when I see them like
encouraging and helping out you know
comics that are coming up because I hate
that [ __ ] thing of you know that
behavior people get to a certain level
then they start treating you know and
I'm here and you're there it's all
stupid it's just like it's you know
you're great like that like the way that
you kind of mentor younger comedians I
mean I try not to be in it I mean I
remember most people were nice but I
definitely member want people who
weren't not necessarily the names but I
just remember how that made me feel so
it's it's sort of the same thing too
with being like a parent and stuff I
remember the good days at school and I
remember the bad day so I don't know how
much fun it was playing with the other
kids at school and then I almost
remember how bad it was if you know you
wore the wrong shirt or whatever it's
just it was just your day to take the
pounding and just like how you could
just literally beginning you know it's
literally like your world and that's
something that I'm hoping I'm gonna be
able to remember which I think I will is
my kids going through school as far as
knowing that though I mean those days I
mean who the hell knows with all the
[ __ ] cameras out there I don't like
it if anything my buddy was just telling
me you know some key told this story
there was some kid everybody picked on
that day and then the kids who picked on
him they found out who all of them were
and they had to go see the [ __ ]
psychology
[ __ ] and I was really thinking about
that's the cyclamen like nobody like
there was none of that at all mm-hmm
like the guidance counselor was just
some weirdo down the hall and he would
just he just would talk to he would only
really talk to kids who had no hope of
going to college right and he just be
down there like well hey man you know
like maybe you get into construction you
know I mean I never even talked to her I
just I don't know what he talked to him
about maybe they have home lives and
[ __ ] maybe he's like a therapy thing but
like only the [ __ ] up kids got
guidance right he's weird everybody else
was just like all right you're following
the cattle right over the [ __ ] cliff
go to school two years of language get
into college pick a major decide what
the [ __ ] you want to do at 18 and then
hit yeah it was one of those things in
them I remember when I was 15 there was
like this like woman that came to the
school that was supposedly like a career
counselor oh good and she came with this
huge book that looked like yellow pages
or something right
and everyone had to have an appointment
and and you'd go in and she'd be like
okay so now what do you want to do and
like someone be like I want to be a
[Laughter]
doctor and so I walked in she's like so
what do you want to do like that
wouldn't be a musician and she's like
sorry there's no musician here what what
else would you like to do I just walked
out oh you walked out what did she do I
don't know how's it I would have but
yeah I would have had like an epiphany
being like wow I mean how many of these
[ __ ] kids wanted to do something
that's not in this book right yeah but
then you have to look at earth just like
there's no way that was her dream in
life they have a yellow book and talk to
people half your age what do you want to
do I want to be a zookeeper all right
let's get to the Z's all right you have
any khaki shorts so you literally have
somebody who didn't follow a dream
talking you out of yours and you had the
strength to [ __ ] walk away from that
that's very very commendable
so that's that those are the moments in
life that haunt me that I think that
into my life when somebody said
something negative and thank God you
know I I didn't latch onto it totally in
somebody else like cuz I have like I
have like there's like three mic moments
in my life you know like climbing up a
[ __ ] cliff that if I went to go this
way I would have fell back down and and
just the luck of it sometimes when I
think of it like God what if I didn't
meet this person
you know and why anyway I worked with
this guy in a warehouse and I finally
found somebody that was into comedy the
way I was and he understood that you
could become it you know what I mean
like he was going like dude these guys
on TV and not funny man one of these
days I'm gonna take a shot at Jack
Daniels and just go on stage and do it
and all of a sudden like cuz it just you
know it was on TV that was like a
million miles away there was no [ __ ]
internet or anything and we had nobody
had video cameras nothing so it just
seemed impossible it didn't even seem
impossible didn't even I didn't even
enter my brain be like [ __ ] going to
the moon and all of a sudden he was just
next to me going I'm gonna [ __ ] do it
and I was just thinking like well [ __ ]
if he can try it I'm gonna try it so if
I don't run into him and if he doesn't
have the balls to say I'm gonna try it
then I'm just [ __ ] hanging out with
other knuckleheads like me drinking then
then all of a sudden I'm 30 and where
the [ __ ] am I you know so but do you
believe like in like a destiny like you
believe that if that wouldn't have
happened something else would have
happened or do you believe like it I
don't believe in destiny because of
tragedy right I don't think that
anybody's destiny is there the hey thank
god you're not this person I just think
you get lucky you get lucky it's it's
like a half-court shot I would say in a
lot of wait well maybe it's not that
it's it's do you think it's like partly
luck and partly manifestation like if
you really want something you're gonna
create the path for it and it can and it
can go in many directions yeah but I
also feel like and there's also tragedy
which is yeah unavoidable and
unpredictable the trash
of where you're born right what you look
like what race you are what part of the
world you're in like how lucky I was to
be a white guy born in USA you know what
I mean and how lucky I was to be born
outside of Boston had this crazy insane
scene there's like a lot of like you
know hurdles that were like this big and
even then even then because of all the
[ __ ] that even does even if you get
that much of a head start all of this
other [ __ ] that can emotionally [ __ ] you
up can you know I mean I think by the
time I was like nine I had already just
sort of like I had that yeah I don't
give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] I don't
yeah I just didn't give a [ __ ] like
anybody and and but I did you know what
I mean and then that's all your work to
get back to that person who did care and
did want stuff you just is a defense
mechanism you just like yeah I don't
give a [ __ ] oh really is that gonna
happen no and then then what I'm that's
supposed to what make me cry [ __ ] you
like I became that person which is it's
it works as far as to get through that
[ __ ] but as far as getting anything that
you [ __ ] want in life we have to be
open and warm and attract stuff to you
that you want and you're over there with
you oh yeah I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
really 400 pounds in my chest put 500 I
don't give a [ __ ] doing that dumb guy's
[ __ ] yeah there's like yeah it's just
yeah that's that that's the thing when
you're sitting there and it [ __ ]
Boston Garden going how the [ __ ]
if I didn't meet this guy if that guy
didn't say that if I went out that night
and went with those people and did that
you just think of all of that [ __ ]
what if [ __ ] and there's somebody who
went out that night went with those
people and then they [ __ ] sitting in
a cubicle or a jail cell or in a [ __ ]
loveless marriage or something and then
just like why don't that that's
somebody's destiny to be in a loveless
marriage it's like I just I don't
yeah and Karma's another one I don't buy
into i think karma works if you if you
if you believe in it but what do you how
do you define kama that basically if
you're a good person good things happen
but if you're a bad person that's not
what comma is though but in my world it
is but common just like if you like
comma simply means cause and effect so
okay well if you do good things then no
it's not a bad good or bad
you feel like I'm in school again oh no
but you do it you don't you just give me
the F and although summer school like
you you do an action and it causes a
result all right it's as simple as that
that's all comma means that's like being
a Satanist people think that you believe
in the devil and people ran just like
Satanism or whatever they don't even
believe in a heaven or hell or a devil
right it's just they just living for
themselves and everybody say oh they're
into the devil so I always thought
common was like if you're [ __ ] this
hole then bad [ __ ] happens to you know
in my business I'd watch these [ __ ]
people stealing and doing all this [ __ ]
and just look at them and be like well
you know good you know nothing's Bad's
happening them and I've done a bunch of
bad [ __ ] and like over all my life is
good but I you know I've heard a lot of
people and [ __ ] so no and it just it
just simply means that you do an action
and it creates a result so all these
people are using that term incorrectly
yes I just put it in a script
incorrectly for family well it's correct
in that because like a lot of people
think that that's what it what it is but
like when you go to the roots of what
comma is it just simply means like you
do an action that's caused an effect I
saw somebody somebody follow an
Instagram they had a picture of a
boomerang and it said karma on it so
that's actually wrong oh my god I wish I
knew the real definition then I could
have been that pompous ass on the
internet being like actually none of you
guys that's like one time I saw this guy
talking about how he didn't have white
privilege and his idea that he didn't
have white privilege is because he
wasn't born rich and he had to work for
the things that he had so his idea is
that white privilege just means you're
born on a yacht and all of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] is like no that's not what that
means that means at no point will you
with because of your seeding just get
pulled over for being white
get this [ __ ] kicked out of you you know
and and all of these other things that
would have happened to you you just you
basically because you had to work for
things you feel you're not privileged so
literally his definition was privilege I
always give you any more details of it
I'll tell you afterwards all right how
do you how do you deal with like
internet troll II type people like have
you ever struggled with that or wanted
to interact with people like that
early on I did but not it has nothing to
do with me yeah yeah it has nothing to
do the amount of [ __ ] that I hate that
really just has to do with me and my day
right that I do and other people do that
to I don't think you know any different
than they are but like yeah I don't give
a [ __ ] I don't have to be a specific
thing that I did and I thought it was
bad too and then everybody said you
shouldn't have done that blah blah blah
I don't like I don't know what but if
it's just like you know you know so much
of whatever you post isn't about what
you posted it's about what's in the
background oh my god that's [ __ ]
great but what's up with that [ __ ]
picture on the wall laughing my ass off
like that's like but what I learned
after a while is like that's their
moment right on the thread right like
I'm gonna be the guy that notices the
thing that starts and then everybody's
talking about what I wanted to talk
about and then it's just a weird thing
when you feel good but like I I I do the
same thing if I send out a tweet and it
gets a bunch of retweets and likes I'm
like alright people thought that was
funny so I'm just on the other end of it
so I just learned like I can't get upset
that somebody is noticing something in
this and now they're doing that little
show like who the [ __ ] am I it's like
you don't want so I'm gonna do that
don't post something on there and I just
look at like listen you don't want
people saying a bunch of bad [ __ ] about
you don't put your face on the Internet
it's like you're literally asking for it
you're sticking your chin out yeah and
they're winding up and punching you and
then you're acting like a victim it's
like well you [ __ ] don't post [ __ ]
just sit there like this or you know
post it take a few shots and continue on
I guess as a musician like well firstly
like as an instrumental musician there's
nothing anybody can say about
like what I'm saying I'm not expressing
an opinion I'm just playing notes right
but then now I've just put out an album
of songs with lyrics and there's only
been a thank you all right
no what I'm saying is that in the
context of the song and I'm very much
expressing like stories that are
personal but like to go out there as a
comedian and like express really strong
opinions like I can't imagine like the
difference in like the kind of feedback
that you get and what people do is you
have to understand that what they do is
they don't like I've always said these
like you can do 80 jokes in a row and
someone will sit there laughing and
enjoying your set and then the 80 first
one has to do something about them it's
a fat joke and they're fat right if it's
about women and they're a woman or it's
about this state and they're from there
and then all of a sudden yeah it's funny
is think that then they go that
statement you made about Arkansas and
it's just like no no they were also they
are all jokes except for the one right
you don't I mean so there's this this
that you know there's just that that
thing I just II I don't pay it any mind
and yeah if there was ever any sort of
big dust-up about something I said if I
actually looked at and thought I said
something wrong I'd be like I well maybe
I'll phrase it a different way but like
I I do think it's absolutely ridiculous
that people get offended about a joke
that was told at a show that they
weren't at and this is taken so out of
context and you know you wanted to show
yeah and you chose to click on that
thing and the tears another thing too if
the comedian didn't film it and post it
yeah if just some [ __ ] [ __ ] in the
crowd did get mad at them yeah and it's
just like well what the [ __ ] are you
doing if you're this easily offended
about stand-up comedy what are you doing
watching watching stand-up comedy the
whole thing is so like I just saw I
think was in Australia like the first
mammal went extinct due to glue human
global warming and barely barely a word
about it but like all of this [ __ ] you
know [ __ ] you know it's more difficult
to be a comedian if you're a woman
[ __ ] me too
it's all about us and what we're going
through and blah blah blah blah and all
of this [ __ ] and just meanwhile all of
that pales in comparison to you know if
this [ __ ] place isn't here you're not
gonna have to worry about any of that
right that's why I think that the
cellphones are super destructive like
because they are making everything about
me me me look what I'm doing look like
where I am
look what I'm eating it so and and we're
on it constantly and it's like whoa did
you see Chris D'Elia Eufaula did you see
his thing that he did the the
unfollowing No oh my god it's one of my
favorite things ever he's talking about
it's just making fun of Instagram models
I mean I can do it I don't feel like I'm
doing this joke because he put it out
there he goes look he goes if you're on
Instagram
it goes and your posts and stuff you
just taking a picture of your booty and
your titties he goes make no mistake you
hook it and he just starts calling them
hookers and and you know and then he
just starts really like something some
of these people I didn't even know
[ __ ] exist it I guess there's this
thing that pretty girls do with a bite
into a sandwich and they kind of look up
like that right saying like yeah yeah
that I'm gonna start this thing called
the unfollowing and what I love about it
is first of all I'm seeing him turning
the corner as a comedian cuz he was
always just he just had that this guy's
a claw like a [ __ ] closer you know
and now he's getting he's like fine in
his like like this razor because he was
always kind of fun and energetic and
stuff and but now it's it's like it's
like it's becoming this you seeing this
force going in this direction like I was
[ __ ] cry and laugh like night I'm not
afraid few things along those lines make
me laugh and it's just really [ __ ]
was making me laugh but the funniest
thing about that is that would really
bother somebody like that like because
they're living not that I would want to
hurt those people because it's very easy
to hate beautiful people you know what I
mean it just is they're very hateable as
you're staring at them because you hate
yourself like why am i this [ __ ]
obsessed with like this beauty and all
of this stuff like like look at you got
like like
[ __ ] through nine hours of [ __ ]
specials to get half as many followings
as you do because you were a [ __ ]
half shirt you know so I just there was
just something funny to just finally see
a movement to make their numbers go down
I don't know the more I'm saying this
out loud I'm actually realizing that
it's kind of says more about me than
about those people that take those
pictures but it's I don't know I just
thought it was it that [ __ ] is funny so
I'm actually watching that girl at the
gas station I'm gonna try to take like
this morning I didn't have my phone you
know when I spent the entire like two
and a half hours I had with my daughter
this morning
chased her around we play with the
puzzles I read the books what else did
we do was teach her how to play catch
and I think she's gonna throw out the
left hand which would be really cool
although she's really big with the
Darryl Dawkins over-the-top sort of
two-handed slam I know you're not gonna
know that reference he played for the
76ers before you were born
so I'm trying to get her not to be into
stuff like that but the weird thing is
is because they're so hyper with their
energy and all you want to do is just
hold them and hug them the best way to
do that is if you put on their favorite
cartoon and then they just snuggle up
next to but then there's no interaction
other than the physical because then you
just literally saying like hey hey hey
you know give me a kiss give me a kiss
and they'll go like they'll just sort of
lean into you and not even look at you
just give you the cheek and they just
sort of lasered into that and I'm like I
don't know I watched a lot of TV I did
all right in life the [ __ ] you're gonna
do I've been allowed to watch TV and
look at you a [ __ ] talented you are
and I'm up there just screaming yelling
like a lunatic where can people get this
album anyway yeah listen to music can
they download it on iTunes yeah I don't
think it's true things gonna be sent on
this podcast than that yeah I can't cuz
my [ __ ] computer's filled up and I
forget my password all the time well I
just want to congratulate you because I
know you worked so hard on this
yeah it's just assembling a ban and all
of that type of stuff like there's so
much more work to this where I just like
I need annoyed a new hour I don't have
to find a mic stand guy and all of this
[ __ ] I just have to go out and just go
do it but whatever you did the three
songs that I listen to I mean it is just
it's on such a high level creativity and
everything I'm really happy for you and
everybody watching listening because
there are gonna be some clips of this on
video please download and it is called
love remain love remains alright thank
you for coming on I was gonna ask you
how do you stop doing ohms and oz and
your nose and [ __ ] like that
how do i ya know I don't I do it all you
do it all the time why cuz I get
something no cuz you do it I do it so
much how I do it too how you do and you
don't care I don't give a [ __ ] do you
listen to uh Keith Richards TMJ people
can't understand him he doesn't give a
[ __ ] but like what about when you're
doing material I guess because you've
written the material that's gonna be
less of that because you know what
you're about to say as opposed to if
you're just doing a podcast if I was
actually trying to work on something
like that then I would be up here which
is not where I wanted right yeah I want
to be it's just coming down the rain
spout and out my [ __ ] would that be
like considered technique for a comedian
to like at some point work on that yes
it would where is like with like I'll
own where I started taking from lessons
from Davey Lich how many like how much
you know of the way I was playing was
getting in the way of me getting to
where I wanted to be with whatever
because my my technique I was like
sitting like this and I was grabbing the
sticks like that was getting blisters
and and I like I wasn't making gravity
anything that had to do with physics
work for me so I was literally fighting
the drum kit and then he taught me all
of this stuff I've seen him in a couple
of months of them going back to my bad
old habits but there is that thing I
think that like Y will say with like a
musician
I wanna learn how to read man I just
wanna you know I just wanna [ __ ] be
this you know free [ __ ] thing right
and just there is merit in that because
you do have those people who only can
play if there's sheet music in front of
them but if you can somehow marry both
of those where you actually have
technique but you can still play from
here yeah and not be up there I think
that that's like the promised land and I
always kind of felt is a comedian if you
could somehow combine Richard Pryor that
specially did live in concert on Long
Beach if you could combine that with
George Carlin where his stuff was just
like I feel like he knew every [ __ ]
word that he was going to say and it was
like yeah just like up up up up up the
whole time where Pryor you know on that
special came walking out it was like a
hell gig there was people walking around
and [ __ ] and he just started making fun
of people and I think the way he was
wired that helped him that helped him
better than if everyone was just sitting
there staring at him like okay begin
your your stand-up special I think that
he came out and you know set yo hands
down you know sit your [ __ ] ugly ass
down what all that stuff that he was
saying and everybody's just walking
around he's riffing and then he just
just got in a zone and what's amazing
you know if she began to his own usually
that lasts for like six minutes because
what happens up to six minutes of that
is you're like you'd start worrying
going well what happens when this ends
and I have to go into my act I'm gonna
be [ __ ] and you you can't think that
because that it's almost like when you
ever try like meditating yeah so you
know like when you start to feel like
you're floating and like leaving your
body if you start thinking oh my god
this is great
Aaliyah and then you go right back down
so that's the same way with like like
catching a stone so like what I've
learned a little I know about technique
with like drums is you just practice a
little bit every day and then when it
starts to become this thing you don't
have to think about then all those
skills you learned about sort of leaving
your body and you
like just like I mean your body's there
but you're listening to what you're
playing that's making you do that next
thing if you can exist you can go back
there with all this technique now you're
not gonna get hurt you're not gonna get
tired I'm eventually will but like so I
think what the comedian if if I was to
try to do that like okay maybe I won't
curse as much or something like that
like I that would definitely be a few
steps backwards by that man maybe it
would help me I don't know I I don't
think I don't think okay cuz if I go up
there and I start doing that it's all
about not being here um I mean I said
I'm obviously thinking like okay I'm
gonna it's more like okay you okay just
walk out I just start talking and then
this joke comes out and then I said this
joke which made me think oh yeah I have
this joke and look at this [ __ ] guy
and then it just sort of just oh now
we're over here and just you just do you
have a like a set list of jokes like you
want to do it in this order or this
order yeah but that is all out the
[ __ ] window the second I go up there
yeah and so well some nights it goes
like that and then other nights like I
definitely have like sections but this
some nights I just go out there and all
of a sudden I tell the last joke first
and I'm switching everything around and
then the guy I taught it to go on stage
going like dude I don't know what the
[ __ ] was going on oh you did you closed
a bit in the middle is like way he's
only doing thirty five minutes and then
you went on you did like another you
know whatever another 25 after that or
something I have like the main setlist
you know so that's the you know this is
the plan the general [ __ ] plan and
then go out there and [ __ ] happens
you're in a weird mood somebody says
something as you look at something in
the back of the room that makes you
think of something and then it go it
goes in that direction and and I am a
full believer of doing that because then
it doesn't become this grind because I
used to I used to have I start with this
and then that leads to this and I have
my segues and pop up
and it just became like you know it's
rigid yeah and then I would be on stage
and my mouth would be talking and I
would find myself thinking about going
like well the second show
if the headliner lets me not close it
out I could probably be home by and then
I was just right yeah
and then I'll say like wait I'm talking
right now and people are laughing and
I'm thinking about other [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] am i doing right now and I uh
it's weird I learned how to free myself
up through why more through watching
musicians I've always equated it to
music because that's something that I
sort of started with so I always thought
I remember talking to a long time ago
late great Patrice O'Neal and I said I
was telling him I was like you know I
always wish I could see somebody cuz I
couldn't gauge how good you were you
know you can't see how good you are how
much you're improving cuz you're you you
don't I mean you're just in there so I
always said I always wanted to say I
wish I could just have somebody sit down
and play guitar at the level of comic
that I am right now it's like could they
change chords could they play without
looking could they solo like where am I
on that trajectory it's one of the few
times he didn't give me any [ __ ] he was
just like huh I guess that's actually
interesting then probably I reacted to
that and then he probably trashed me
because he actually opened up for half a
second so yeah fascinating fascinating
nuts and bolts of how to tell dick and
[ __ ] jokes will continue after these
messages from stamps calm all right all
baby boop boop biondi's biondi's old red
face is in [ __ ] Iceland doo doo doo
doo be undies be undies he's eating
[ __ ] frozen bison and he's not gonna
pee his underwears cuz they're made out
of soft Mick moto a motel so who [ __ ]
cares me undies there are two types of
dudes in the world those that go through
the gate and those that go over the
fence well after years of research and
countless experiments with seasoned
underwear scientist me undies now has an
option for both with their new boxer
briefs
with a fly it took a while but now man
on both sides of the aisle enjoy the
world's softest undies not only will you
feel like your loins are being hugged by
joy itself but me undies gives you
multiple style options for men and women
men can wear can now try the new
boxer-brief with a fly it's the same
great cut as boxer briefs just a hole
now for number 1 okay
the undies is also the go-to for the
softest long-wear on the planet hangout
and they're super cup well you're gonna
hang out with that hole in your under
whis hangout and they're super comfy
lounge pants and onesies yes beyond Z's
makes onesies and their Incredibles
Incredibles like the movie me undies has
a great offer for my listeners at any
first for any first-time purchasers you
can get 15% off and free shipping get
15% off prepare the most comfortable
undies you will ever put on to get your
15% off your first pick pair free
shipping on a hunt percent satisfaction
guarantee you go to me undies comm / /
that's me undies com / / alright
LegalZoom everybody it's zoomin in a
legal way they're running a small
business has a lot of work I am so tired
of running my small business it takes
time and money and you want all the time
and money you have to go towards growing
your business but what happens when
LegalZoom hurdles what what happens when
legal hurdles pop up along the way Legal
Zoom is there to help nearly 2 million
Americans have used Legal Zoom to stat
their businesses with LLC's and
corporations in moola
but even after your business is set up
Legal Zoom can still help out things
like lease agreements changing tax laws
and contract reviews all part of running
your own business and these are
precisely the kinds of costly hurdles
that can take time away from your
growing business that's why Legal Zoom
created their business legal plan get
advice for running your business from
vetted independent attorneys and tax
professionals available in all 50 states
the best part is you won't get charged
by the hour since Legal Zoom is not a
law firm make your time and money work
for you check out Legal Zoom business
legal plan at legalzoom.com now and
enters and get special savings when you
enter BRR
at checkout be you are our legalism
where life meets legal legalzoom.com
okay next what do we got all right
butcher blocks dude butcher box delivers
healthy 100% grass-fed and
grass-finished beef free-range organic
chicken and heritage breed pork my
favorite the incredible quality of
butcher bucks means meats start with an
with the commitment to raise animals
humanely and free of antibiotics and
hormones before they're slaughtered each
box comes at least eight to eleven
pounds of meat which is enough for 24
individual size meals or if you got
giantism it's probably a slider you can
choose from five different box types all
beef beef and chicken beef and pork
ladies mix box custom box let you choose
your own cuts like a real American my
favorite is the heritage breed pork the
butcher box difference butcher box meats
come from humanely raised open pasture
animals that frolic and are never fed
antibiotics hormones or fatty livers
they listen to cat the captain and
Tennille before getting whacked get the
ultimate breakfast bundle that's two
packages of bacon and two pounds of
breakfast soffit sausage for free in
your first box plus $20 off your first
box go to butcher box.com slash burn or
enter the promo code bur last but not
least Dollar Shave Club now you'll have
the smoothest balls in the block dollish
Dollar Shave Club has everything you
need to look feel and smell your best
and you never have to go to a store
that's because they deliver everything
you need right to your door and they
keep you fully stocked on what you you
use so you don't run out here's how it
works Dollar Shave Club has everything
you need to get ready no matter what
you're getting ready for they have you
cut they have you covered head to toe
for you heya your skin your face you
name it they have it and they have this
new program where they automatically
keep your stocked up on the products you
use you determine what you want and when
you want it and it shows up right here
Dilla from once a month to once every
six months plus they're handsome
discount the more you buy the more you
say the right
now Dollar Shave Club has a bunch of
status sets you can try for just 5 bucks
like their oral care kit
Jesus you had a rough weekend didn't you
sweet hood alright after that after that
the the restock box ships regular size
products at regular prices at the
regular price get stat get you started
set for just five dollars right now at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / berg and now for a
bill bus theme song oh I get a theme
song out of this I would have thought it
would have been on like a ukulele some
sort of Irish jig saw do they play
ukuleles out there I don't know you have
to play that seriously I have to play
yeah why do I have to because I'm gonna
sing your theme song well then you have
to tell it joke I have to tell a joke
well why do I have to do my hobby uh do
you know what I mean what am i playing
doom doom crack okay then play it really
softly is that pianoforte could you just
just make sure you do the [ __ ] huh the
[ __ ] yeah I learned how we're gonna
[ __ ] in the end all right yeah
[Music]
that's how that's the end that's the
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
like a soldier
caught between this
[Music]
the time hey what's going on it's bill
burr and it's the Monday morning podcast
for Monday April 25th 2011 how the [ __ ]
are you yeah well that's good I'm in a
good mood here I adjusted the levels
this week let me know how you guys have
if this is too loud because some
truckers some truckers some truckers
wrote me a name and I'm driving across
this [ __ ] country bringing bacon and
beer to all these fat [ __ ] out here and
well my well my well my rig gets a
rumbling I can't hear your podcasts
there come on good buddy can you turn it
up for me you got your ears on or that
whole [ __ ] phenomenon back in the 70s
you guys old enough to remember that
[ __ ] when having a CB and being a
[ __ ] redneck trucker was actually in
for half a second and I'm not talking
about that Ashton Kutcher horseshit when
he walked around with this [ __ ]
greasy trucker hat right before he
started banging that [ __ ] hot mom up
there in Wyoming with their big fake
[ __ ] tits I'm not talking about that
his trucker hat that actually said Von
Dutch on it do you guys even know what
the [ __ ] that was I didn't until I moved
out to LA and realized that that was the
guy who did all the custom paint on the
hot rods is that what the [ __ ] it was
I'm talking about before that I'm
talking about when when there were shows
on TV with guys who hung out with
monkeys and it was our Clint Eastwood
was making movies with monkeys like that
was like those were like the vampire
movies of the late 70s he had any which
way but loose any which way you can
why the [ __ ] am i doing a trilogy with
an orangutan I think was the last one
that he did and they even had a TV show
it's my voice cracks they've been a TV
show called BJ in the bear and the bear
was had a hat on like Paul Bear Bryant
who was the old coach of the [ __ ]
Alabama Crimson Tide and I didn't get
that you know because what were they
saying about him you know they calling
him a monkey is that
just to call a white man a monkey oh
Jesus
this is the podcast for this week ladies
and gentlemen so this is this is gonna
be the levels I adjusted the bass
somebody said the the bass was too
[ __ ] low like I have all these
buttons on these none these goddamn
thing I don't know how to work it so I
just realized that there's a high amid
and a low range so gradually eventually
this podcast will become professional
look at me I'm pacing around I'm pacing
around my old [ __ ] bedroom that's
what I'm doing here on Easter [ __ ]
Easter Sunday
did you guys sod you guys go to church
holy holy holy
eat this [ __ ] wafer it's the body of a
guy who came out of womb that was never
[ __ ] is that what you guys did did you
give your little colored eggs for the
[ __ ] weed smokers man I'm [ __ ]
tired I'm just I'm trying to go on
energy this week people I just that was
just you know I was like you know
remember back in the day when you get
into a fight with somebody who knew you
were gonna lose so you just had that
first [ __ ] eight seconds of the fight
we like just swinging before he just
started punching in the head and you
started crying then the girl you had a
crush on that's the first person when
you looked up that's the one you always
saw but the dirt in the side of your
face and the [ __ ] pebble stuck in
your skin and you just she just you know
you don't know what killed you is she
didn't look away she was walking away
but she was making eye contact
and she didn't know what she was
thinking because she was so young but it
was just her inner DNA was clicking in
already that was just letting her know
was just giving her innocent little stay
away from that you know when she gets
older it gets more sophisticated with
you cannot breed with that when you're
young it's just sort of he looks icky um
anyways the [ __ ] was I talking about I
was talking about truckers let's let's
work our way back here BJ and McKay BJ
McKay and his best friend Bear is there
any truckers listen to this [ __ ] and
that's why you became a trucker
you know you'll flunk in math
you sucked in English class history
didn't interest you and then one day
there was a show they'll let you know
that your dream of someday driving a
truck with the chimpanzee could come
true what the [ __ ] dude
speaking it did I mentioned this week
that I was gonna have a couple of guests
on the Monday morning podcast not one
guest not two guests but two guests
sorry it's got to be three right you
always got to say not this not this but
this which is a hard thing to do when
the numbers too but I plowed through it
I'm gonna have two guests and I was
thinking of doing it on this podcast and
I was like you know what well why don't
I do two podcasts this week why don't I
over indulge like all the kids running
around with their [ __ ] candy not
really learning the story of Jesus is in
this store this is the day about the
conquering of life over death right I
read a little bit everybody was thinking
Jesus was dead they were like I can't
believe it he was the number one draft
pick dude we was supposed to get the
championship but what does he do he
[ __ ] shits the bed on Friday where is
he where the [ __ ] is he
last I heard he was in a cave hiding
behind a rock he's [ __ ] dead his
careers over
it's it we need them we need to go to
another motivational speaker and then
what happens all of a sudden some nosy
prick walked in right started rolling
the rock back probably the original
Geraldo Rivera you know with some just
[ __ ] amazing medieval mustache and he
came walking in there and Jesus was just
laying there right if I can overuse this
reference for the 500th time in two
weeks lay in there like [ __ ] Burt
Reynolds but that leaf over his [ __ ] why
do I talk about that so much do I have a
crush on Burt Reynolds oh do you a
[ __ ] queer sorry and adjusting like
that um no it's just [ __ ] it's just
hilarious to me I love the 70s I loved
what you could get away with you know so
anyways so Jesus is laying there right
and his Playgirl [ __ ] spread
hippie hair laying down you know and
then let me see if I can remember this
some church and then these like there
was like at least three guys came
walking in and they were the guys who
hung out with them at his last supper
right before Judas betrayed him do you
know Jesus now I do it I don't know that
[ __ ] what do you think he's
gonna say you just nailed him to a
[ __ ] piece of wood give a [ __ ] who it
is up on that I don't know that guy yeah
good for you way to go Jesus let's get
the [ __ ] out of here I really think I
think Judas gets a bad rap look I think
you should always stick by your friends
but Jesus Christ what the [ __ ] he's
supposed to doing then it's over you
know do you realize the nerve damage
you're gonna get if somebody drives the
nails I have heard different things
through the hands or through the
forearms you know in between the radius
and ulna the [ __ ] nerve damage you're
gonna get at that point right there not
you're not coming back from that he
can't continue being a carpenter wait a
minute he's his son of God why didn't he
just just you know hover off that thing
and make and just go here and then he
was better why didn't he do that you
know why I didn't do that because then
he couldn't guilt you for your entire
life
look at me look what I did happy Easter
everybody
so anyways they [ __ ] so yeah so the
guy dies right he dies and he's like oh
god what did we do then it started
raining really bad and then Steve
Carrell put a bunch of animals on a boat
right he saved them no wait then those
three guys who find him in the cave
would have been dead because they
weren't on the boat
alright let's back up let's back up to
12 a s that no no BS before Steve before
Steve Carrell beast BSC all right what
the [ __ ] are my three [ __ ] guys
walking to the damn cave and then they
go hey are you sleeping are you awakened
Jesus now I'm up you know like you're
not Jesus we saw you you
and they go it is me and then and then
they didn't believe it was him and then
they were in trouble you know then they
were sitting next to Judas at the
[ __ ] bench outside the principal's
office waiting to go in and see God why
did you say you didn't know my son you
know my son you've been over my house
what is your story Judas why did you
deny him hey listen man you know I would
anyone any trouble the guy was you know
I was coming to get you that didn't you
know Judas is basically that [ __ ] guy
was it Bobby in Saturday Night Fever
remember that [ __ ] when he drove away
and he didn't fight
that's who Judas is is he built yeah I
think he is according to my version my
new version of the Old Testament is it's
the Old Testament of the new the new one
whatever
so these [ __ ] guys walk in and then
basically how they figure out it's Jesus
is he takes one of their hands and he
puts it into the wound on the side of
him and then they go oh yeah it is you
it was weird because I hung out with you
and I know what your face looks like but
unless I stuck my hand inside your
[ __ ] chest cavity III wasn't really
convinced wait a minute yeah yeah feel
that liver tell me that's not Jesus
that's him let's [ __ ] him so yeah
that's the history of the Jesus part of
it dude it is hot as [ __ ] in this room
I'm in my old apartment I have to have
the doors closed
also anyways yeah so I decided I was
gonna do two podcasts this week I'm
gonna do the regular one the regular one
where I ramble and I piss off [ __ ]
Jesus freaks and talk to truckers
talking to truckers what do you guys do
in your trucks you got the Confederate
flags do you go yeehaw
when you change lanes I'm you know you
like me like one when when liberals do
[ __ ] like that that's one thing I've
noticed about liberals they're as [ __ ]
up to the left as the people all the way
on the right you know there is
intolerant you know am i preaching Jesus
it's hot in here
this isn't me I don't preach do I don't
[Music]
I'm just trying to get my bearings here
people the [ __ ] was I talking auga then
he got the Easter Bunny
alright and according to Wikipedia the
Easter Bunny came from Germany you know
so all you people out there
think Germans are the most evil
[ __ ] on the planet just because
they started two world wars and tried to
wipe an entire group of people off the
face of the earth by sticking them in
ovens you know yeah all right you got
him they're a little evil there but you
know what they got a soft side they got
a soft side and his name is Peter
Cottontail right here comes Peter
Cottontail up and down the bunny trail
hippity hoppity [ __ ] you [ __ ]
right one of the few Easter songs I ever
knew he's got jelly beans for Bobby
colored eggs first sister sue so anyways
I guess they brought that tradition over
here and people have always asked the
Seinfeld Ian question why do they have
eggs come on Ruben because evidently
there was a sign of fertility
I guess according to Wikipedia basically
birds you know they lay a bunch of eggs
very fertile and bunny rabbits when they
when they get [ __ ] knocked up all
right when some [ __ ] hair starts
pulling the back of their ears is he's
[ __ ] jackhammer and in the back of
that little rabbit [ __ ] what comes out
right like [ __ ] 48 rabbits every
goddamn time
that's why snakes are so fat it's just
that just not that this there's just
plenty of rabbits to feast on right I
don't [ __ ] know people like glance at
this [ __ ] right before I started the
podcast so basically they combined the
two of those I don't know why the whole
[ __ ] thing is weird and it has to do
with life I guess and Jesus coming back
from the dead coming back to life and
the eggs the latter [ __ ] though it
makes no goddamn sense to me I mean you
know what it is I think the story of
those guys walking into the cave and
somebody getting nailed to a goddamn
cross and then somebody having to stick
their hand in the side of a human being
like they're reaching into a giant
wallet was just too good
was just too creepy to say to kids so
you gotta come up with this [ __ ]
right you know it's pre TV what do you
do just give him a basket full of
[ __ ] colored eggs and some candy you
know when I was a kid I thought those
Cadbury eggs were chocolate [ __ ] eggs
remember then the [ __ ] rabbit was
sitting there I thought that and I
thought they were disgusting and I have
a sweet tooth and I never got him
because when they broke them open it
looked like a [ __ ] egg yolk inside of
it and I was like there's no way that is
that's I don't want a chocolate-covered
egg oh let's get on with the podcast for
this week I have a couple announcements
so what I was what I was trying to say I
don't know if I've said at this point
this is why I never do podcast when I
travel but I had I had a quick trip came
in from Detroit so rather than just do
the one podcast and have Bobby Bobby
Bobby Kelly my old roommate we're gonna
tell stories about how we used to live
together and we almost beat the [ __ ] out
of each other and that time you threw
the racquetball when I had the Conan
O'Brien audition and it reca shade off
the wall went into the bathroom and hit
me in the mouth and cut my [ __ ] lip
right before I had to go down and
showcase for the Conan people as he was
riding on this bootleg Stairmaster that
he [ __ ] took off the sidewalk because
he grew up in a [ __ ] junkyard all
right that's one of the stories we'll be
telling and then we're also going to be
lucky enough to have the teen idol
sensation from the Opie and Anthony
program Joe DeRosa everybody Joe DeRosa
is also going to be on the Monday
morning podcast this special edition the
limit the Shelby gt500 edition of this
[ __ ] podcast oh speaking of
which last week
we added a donation button a bunch of
people donated I really appreciate it
you know I'm able to [ __ ] pay my web
guy few more [ __ ] dog and eventually
you know I'm gonna be able to hire
somebody to help me with this mixer so
it sounds okay I'm gonna have a whole
little [ __ ] radio station I'm taking
this thing too
the next level people but some of you
guys were actually having difficulty
finding the the podcast donation button
if you just go on the MMP dot-com the
official fan page of the Monday morning
podcast if you just go on there if you
look under the icons on the right you'll
see the Twitter Facebook and something
else over there those icons you know
right underneath that you'll see donate
and there's a big donate button you just
click on that whatever you want to give
people been given like 10 20 bucks the
average has been about 20 bucks I've had
a couple of ridiculous
donations from people and I tried to
write back as many as you can as I could
to say thanks I'm gonna write back some
more today after I do this but I really
appreciate you guys kicking in and all
the positive feedback I got I really
appreciate you guys kicking in for this
thing and I'm gonna take the money and
reinvest into this [ __ ] thing and I've
realized I got myself a little radio
show here I'm kind of excited kind of
excited about this and I want to take it
to another level and speaking of another
level the Tribeca Film Festival has
begun and cheat the film that we did our
film cheat as I should say debuted last
night and they put us on at the end of 8
different films and evidently I wasn't
there Joe DeRosa fresh off his [ __ ]
cover shoot of teen Beat Magazine was
there and once he got done signing
autographs were all the kids he went in
and evidently according to him I got a
text he said the film [ __ ] killed and
Anna can't even tell you last time I was
that excited I was like really nervous
and I got to give him kudos cuz I
wouldn't have the balls to sit there
just the unbelievable lack of power that
you'd have in that situation et and I'm
standing it's live if it's not funny I
can do something about it in the moment
even though I'm doing like the podcast I
can feel when it's not funny I'll make I
can do something but film is done and
you just sit in there and if it's not
work and you can't stop it you can't
you can't feed the crowd you just
sitting there it's done but evidently he
sat there and i guess it [ __ ] killed
and we're hoping all the other screens
are gonna go that way pretty much all
the shows are sold out so i want to
thank everybody once again it's a big
love fest here i want to thank everybody
for uh for coming out and supporting the
film i hope you guys enjoyed those you
get tickets those who aren't going to be
able to see it we will definitely figure
out a way to get it out there to you
guys so you will be able to see it and
and with that you want to have something
that's how much of a maniac sports fan i
am though however despite the fact that
i got off stage sold-out show at the
Royal Oak Theatre Royal Oak Michigan I
want to thank everyone who came out for
that [ __ ] thing I get off stage
alright and I am well aware that the
Bruins and the Canadians are in double
overtime now last week if you remember
the Bruins lost the first two all the
Montreal fans are walking away from
their MP [ __ ] three players right now
aren't you where you going come back sit
down sit down and take it a little bit
all right you [ __ ] you sent me
a lot of you snooty little
french-canadian [ __ ] emails talking
about how Boston Bruins were done
because we lost the first two at home
didn't you did look at me come on
Jacques up here I'm up here I'm up here
yeah you sent me a bunch of [ __ ]
emails saying that we were finished
alright now what did I say I said last
week asked not no I said last week that
we weren't finished and I said that we
were gonna [ __ ] kill him in Game
three we didn't kill him but we beat him
alright for those who aren't hockey fans
we beat him in their [ __ ] building
they could have gone up three oh now
it's 2-1 I no big deal just win game for
they're up 3-1 they got another home
game no way the Bruins are gonna win
again it in their [ __ ] building this
is the [ __ ] Montreal Canadiens right
I saw a video on YouTube that was hyping
this series and when the Ollie showed
was the Canadiens kicking the [ __ ] out
of the Bruins even like
modern-day footage them winning fights
everything and then the indie and the
the narrator goes to close it out said
pretty much own the Bruins forever right
now and did that get my blood going it's
like they haven't owned the Bruins since
pre 1988 ok up to 1987 they [ __ ]
owned our asses we couldn't beat them
but since then they've been a non-factor
we've met them ten times in the playoffs
we've beaten him six times the last time
we played them we beat them four games
in a [ __ ] row the last two in their
building I don't get it they're not in
the way of us or anybody else winning a
cup then not who they used to be they
dominated a 16 League that it's that's
it it's over
and then the hangover of the expansion
six until everybody got on their [ __ ]
feet and then the out of the Edmonton
Oilers and the 70s were over they
haven't dominated since all right enough
already with that [ __ ] so anyways
all they got to do is win Game four what
happens the [ __ ] Bruins win it and
overtime now it's 2-2 but going back to
Boston right last night double overtime
[ __ ] game I'm on stage missing every
[ __ ] second of it having the time of
my life though having a great time all
these people showed up and [ __ ]
Detroit absolutely beautiful [ __ ]
town that just needs a coat of paint and
evidently some windows and they really
need to like Detroit looks like a
hurricane came and everybody boarded up
their [ __ ] windows and they never
bothered to take it off that's what
really looks like it's sad because they
had these beautiful brick houses there's
a few cities that I go to when it makes
me sad how beautiful they are and
they've just been run down Detroit
Cleveland Upper Darby when I went there
in a last couple weeks ago did Tower
Theatre and Philly it's just it's just
it's awful it's like you'd be looking at
like 200 seasons of this old house you
could just have a never ending of people
coming in and fixing up these awesome
houses and making them great again but
anyways so I get off stage this is how
much of a [ __ ] it's
like go sports fan am i know that the
our film is debuting at the Tribeca Film
Festival it's the first film I've ever
done like this where I was involved at
this level okay and I opened I look at
my phone and I get a text from Joe
DeRosa right and it says the the film
[ __ ] killed with like 20 exclamation
points behind it so I'm totally psyched
now wouldn't you think that that would
be my first phone call to find it at now
the first thing I'm doing is I'm looking
for texts from fellow Bruins fans and
I'm not getting anything that's letting
me know what happened I got a couple of
texts saying can you [ __ ] believe
this because it was this unbelievable
game and but nothing saying whether they
want to loss and my [ __ ] heart sunk
and it reminded me of the time I was
watched working The Improv in DC and the
[ __ ] Patriots are playing the Colts
in the AFC Championship game and we were
up like 20 to nothing or something at
the half and I got a bunch of calls from
Pats fans but uh Peyton Manning's
choking again can you [ __ ] believe
this
and when all these Pats fans were
already calling me and when I got
offstage when the show was over 90
[ __ ] minutes later after I sold DVDs
probably about two hours later I got off
and I had no text and no messages and I
was like uh-oh called up found out the
[ __ ] Colts actually came back to win
so I get offstage and all I have is
people reacting to the overtime and then
I don't get any [ __ ] text so I
assumed the worst that the Canadiens won
and then I called up somebody I said
what happened eyes [ __ ] squinting cop
made this call before I found out about
the film and what did I find out what
did I find out the [ __ ] Bruins wanted
now we're up three games to two okay
against this team that's pretty much
owned us forever give me a [ __ ] break
you guys owned us and I [ __ ] own the
fact that you owned us but you have not
owned us since 1988 you have not stand
the [ __ ] down it's been a whole
different era since then enough already
you know what it is it's just lazy
sports journalism you just dusting off
that same [ __ ] stupid story enough
already you ought to be ashamed of
yourself whoever wrote that piece all
right two thumbs down from this Bruins
fan so that's the deal dude it's [ __ ]
three to two and now we're going up to
Montreal with once again with an
opportunity to close out the series in
[ __ ] Montreal and not to mention I
also twittered I don't tweet i twitter I
said a few days ago what did I send but
I'm gonna be that guy dude I called it
this week I [ __ ] said this game this
series is going seven and Tim Thomas is
gonna be the difference Carey Price is
not there yet I'm telling you we're
gonna beat these [ __ ]
you hear me Montreal we're gonna [ __ ]
beat you sons of [ __ ] alright and
then what then what then we're gonna be
going on 25 years a quarter of a century
of you guys not owning us are you still
gonna dust that [ __ ] story off it's
over it's over you guys are over and
this [ __ ] series is over cuz we're
closing it out and games I'm [ __ ] with
you
you know I really think is gonna happen
I think I don't think that the Montreal
fans are gonna allow their team to lose
this series in their building you know
this is the one thing I gotta give I got
to give up a couple of things to the
[ __ ] Canadians aside from having one
of the best uniforms and sports despite
the fact that when I look at it makes me
[ __ ] rage I gotta admit it's a great
[ __ ] uniform number two your fans are
[ __ ] ridiculous
they just they're just awesome fans
you're obnoxious your snooty whatever
but I mean though the way that you guys
push your team that's why I think you
guys are gonna win Game six because of
that [ __ ] and also I really hope that
subhan is gonna be a [ __ ] free agent
and we can sign him cuz I think that
guys this [ __ ] and he's gonna be a star
other than that go [ __ ] yourselves go
eat a [ __ ] croissant or whatever and
get ready to start golfing people cuz
this series is [ __ ] oh I'm [ __ ]
with you I never talk [ __ ] like this and
I'm not confident that it's over this
thing changed on a dime and it can
change back again when the [ __ ] am I
gonna get a job in one of these
or channels and put on a sport coat and
sit there with my little pen tapping it
waiting to chime in as the
straight-laced guy you know you know
he's got the straight-laced guy going up
in Montreal with blue block a Rouge or
up above the blue what are you gonna say
about that bill then I'm the [ __ ]
[ __ ] who wears like a short sleeve
shirt under a blazer alright I know
people saying way too much Sports Talk
well why don't you go [ __ ] and read a
book then what do you want me to get
back to my amazing talks about history I
don't know [ __ ]
alright you listen to me hear me itch
and that [ __ ] beard alright I have
another announcement to make this week
Seattle the anti social network tour the
the brilliant comedian comedic in
brainchild whatever whatever what is
that expression whatever the the the the
lineup god damn it I'm trying to hide
this what is the [ __ ] word gives us
[ __ ] I'm too stupid look Jim Norton came
up with this great idea he said you know
what I got a show down in Atlantic City
New Jersey I do it every year what if I
brought down a couple of pals a couple
of buddies brought down Dave Attell Jim
Breuer and myself we had a great time
people showed up we had to add shows we
like holy [ __ ] this could be something
so now we're adding cities the next city
that we are adding is Seattle I and I am
officially announcing Seattle and I am
officially announcing it without the
[ __ ] date of course I am the [ __ ]
worst
I had everything laid out there it is
here it is I got it right no I don't
here's a new button I hit there's the
[ __ ] Easter Egg [ __ ] is this it
bill you're such a dumb [ __ ] oh here we
go all right Seattle should be announced
on Monday April 25th check I am doing
that it goes on sale Friday April 29th
at wwt it's calm the show is on July 1st
at the beautiful the lovely Paramount
Theater
in Seattle Washington you can go to
antisocial comedy calm and facebook.com
slash antisocial comedy will have direct
ticket links in all other show
information and I am going to announce
that says please make sure you announce
this first thing Monday well I think the
Monday morning podcast is the first
perfect vehicle so there you go people
Seattle Washington July 1st tickets go
on sale next Friday April 29th go to
tickets calm antisocial comedy calm or
facebook.com slash antisocial comedy and
come on out and check out three amazing
[ __ ] comedians and myself mopping up
not even mopping up I'm coming out of
the gate anyways was they just gonna say
about Seattle did I have anything else
to hype about that oh I know then we got
we got at that same tour if you like
that lineup and you live in different
parts of the country
that's a west west coast date if you
want a mid west date June 15th we're at
the Chicago Theatre in Chicago Illinois
one of the most underrated cities in
this goddamn country and if you live on
the East Coast May 13th we're gonna be
at Constitution Hall in Washington DC I
can't wait to do that gig cuz fans of
stand-up comedy I might be a little
wrong on a couple of these specials but
I know Eddie Murphy taped delirious
there
I believe Martin Lawrence taped the
special there and Chris Rock did I don't
know which Chris Rock won so I think
it's fitting that four white guys are
now going to come in and hold hands and
do one giant show all right to take that
venue back no I'm kidding um the [ __ ]
was that all about I think that was one
for the truckers
alright let's plow ahead with the
podcast here people enough with the
announcements enough with the [ __ ]
let's get to uh Jesus Christ bill why
don't I have this [ __ ] laid out oh I
know last week I asked you guys I said
can you guys help me out you know by
giving me a little bit of feedback on
last week's podcast to help me keep the
[ __ ] ball in the air here for an hour
and here's something last week we were
talking about STDs somebody wrote in and
was talking about they met this
wonderful lady okay and he goes to the
zoo and they're not looking at the
ostriches they're not looking at the
gorillas they're [ __ ] looking into
each other's eyes and they're just
totally connecting you like juggling I
like juggling right totally headed off
then it finds out she finds out the dude
finds out she's got herpes what do I do
Wow they just remind me that old Sesame
Street song no left turn no right turn
poem what do you do remember that one
every once awhile an old Sesame Street
song pops into my head and you know what
I was thinking the one the other day
do you remember Bob so called white man
remember him from the from Sesame Street
Bob was one of the whitest guys ever and
they sang a song I think it was teaching
you about you [ __ ] the [ __ ] on your
face and everybody's singing I got it I
got a nose I got a mouth I got I got two
ears I got two eyes they're singing this
little ditty I remember Susan the black
girl on there right she sang about the
ears right before Bob and she totally
Sasa's it up which made Bob sound even
whiter I forget all the whole song went
but Susan the black chick went first and
then Bob who made [ __ ] John Denver
looked like a [ __ ] like he was in the
goddamn Crips so she sings about the
ears and then he comes on the song basic
I don't think I remember this she goes I
got two ears to help me and he goes I've
got two eyes that they're both the same
size and I remember being like five or
six years old thinking there was
something wrong with Bob that he
shouldn't have sung it that way
can anybody send me a link to that
I've got two boys Oh Bob what happened
what happened to you how did you grow up
in the 50s isolate it did you have a
bomb shelter did you put your [ __ ]
white head between your white knees out
there in the white cul de sac is that
what happened then you found out you had
a love of music but you couldn't sing
rock and roll so everybody called you a
queer and then what happened you got
into sock puppets the next thing you
know you meet a guy named Jim Henson he
makes a pass at she grabs your ass you
start you shove your face into his beard
you guys are making out right look
disgusting this kid is nobody with the
beard safe on this podcast first Jesus
and now Jim Henson you know it's funny
Jim Henson's bird bird his [ __ ] beard
kind of looks like one of those Easter
Egg basket [ __ ] things right you know
you guys can go [ __ ] yourself right now
I know it's off the rails I know this
whole thing is just gone Ted just went
down an alley that has no exit I'm in
here sweating I shouldn't be sweating
while doing this you know it's funny I
mean I'm in my old bedroom all right
back in the day when I was a single man
when I used to bring back the broads oh
god the nightmares I used to be you know
so you don't really [ __ ] me up was dr.
drew dr. Drew like if I met dr. drew
I've done a show a couple of times right
his love line thing if I did his show 10
[ __ ] years ago I swear to god there
there's a good eight or nine girls I
never would have hooked up with just
it's it's [ __ ] unreal you got to
listen to that guy show I realize the
reason why like probably a third of the
women that I [ __ ] hooked up was I was
damaged and I was going out hooking up
with other damaged people and that was
the connection and then we had this
[ __ ] crazy I'm not even gonna get
into it you gotta listen to his show
he's [ __ ] unreal they sit there they
could people callin that the girls they
have those little mousy voices you know
those voices that turn guys on those
creepy little girl voices today yeah
yeah um my boyfriend he just immediately
goes what happened to you when you were
five and you find out they got molested
when they were five and then there was
some sort of [ __ ] like I don't know
what you call it they just stopped
growing mentally and they kept talking
that way I can't just [ __ ] blows my
mind I'm back in the day when a girl
came up talking like that you like this
girl's easy right talking like pebbles
on the goddamn Flintstones what happened
you dick takes a is an easy one to
[ __ ] knock out of the park I didn't
realize it and I feel like some sort of
[ __ ] pervert
Jesus that wasn't funny at all was it
what was on my chest I had to get it off
all right so let's plow ahead so last
week this person was sitting there
talking about you know so he met some
lady and she had the [ __ ] you know
she's got the blisters on a thing there
right she of course tells an innocent
story of it was one guy and he went down
on me and he had a cold sore and that
was it that's when somebody has an STD
that's always how they tell the story
they never say listen I was an absolute
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I was [ __ ]
everything that moved and I really have
no idea when I got it where I got it or
who I gave it to all I know is I got it
and if you want some of it I got it I
got it right [ __ ] here no one says
that man a woman there was just go I was
on my way to Bible study and somebody
said would you like a drink
I didn't know what was in it oh god it
feels so foolish I feel like you're
judging me and you're like no no I'm not
judging you right no one was getting
banged in a [ __ ] Jacuzzi no one got
it that way did day right no one went
down - what is that Freaknik or what do
they call that hedonism where everybody
goes down to that [ __ ] The Hague
Haiti and [ __ ] you know before the
earthquake I guess they got to move it
now I don't what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about Jamaica is that where you go it's
just [ __ ] crazy
you know or they go down to Brazil he
says like I went to Brazil and banged a
bunch of [ __ ] and I don't even know
what I have
I got I got south-of-the-border [ __ ]
gonorrhea you know no one says that no
one says that there was a mariachi band
and I was banging this girl on the dirt
outside some [ __ ] bar and Tijuana and
that's how I got syphilis no one says
that it's always an innocent [ __ ]
story and they always look down and of
course cuz there's shame involved but no
one will own up to it no one just say
listen you know I banged a lot of broads
and I went in raw all right no vest no
[ __ ] rubber no nothing I stuck it in
there I moved it around I got all up in
that disease and now it's on my dick and
I just thought you should know I add my
time I had a good [ __ ] time
and now I'm paying for it alright you
want to help me limp across the [ __ ]
finish line of life with my blistered
[ __ ] is that what you want to do if
you're up for it I'm just trying to be
upfront what did you order by the way
did you did you start with a you get the
muscles no one says that [ __ ] Jesus bill
we got it so last week I was talking
about say you know what they ought to
add a [ __ ] website for people with
STD so they don't got to go through this
[ __ ] and lo and behold they they got a
[ __ ] site here people let me see what
we got here somebody they got it dude
they pretty much got a [ __ ] website
for everything and I remember those a
guy a few weeks ago this [ __ ] dude
over there he [ __ ] call he called me
up he [ __ ] sent me an email and he
was telling me that they 10 most bizarre
dating websites oh I know what I was
gonna say I can't read and think at the
same time how [ __ ] up is that
or think about something else I can't
multitask this guy sent me this email
and he was saying that uh Jesus the [ __ ]
was it what the [ __ ] was my point
see now my brain is looking at this [ __ ]
my brain it works in a straight line and
just [ __ ] gets erased immediately the
[ __ ] did he say
this is unbelievable is this is this how
Reagan started all right [ __ ] it
I know what the [ __ ] he said oh I
remember I got it now he was talking
about how he didn't want to do the
online dating thing cuz he thought it
was like this host stigma and that type
of [ __ ] and he felt like a loser what
kind of guy can't go out and get laid on
his own and go meet a girl [ __ ] that if
I was a young dude and my goddamn prime
as opposed to a [ __ ] approaching the
end of his middle age which I got to
because you multi-time 'he's 2 is 84
right you think I'm making 85 I Got News
for You I am I'm making 101 I'm gonna
see the 70s again 2070 I'm checking out
I'm calling it right here that's my
prediction
Nostradamus on my own [ __ ] life did
he ever do that with himself that
arrogant prick dude Nostradamus is so
[ __ ] overrated it's ridiculous doing
the future bad shits gonna happen really
there's gonna be a guy with a beard
saying something to a bald guy oh my god
dude that's Saddam that's Gorbachev no
you know what that is that's like when
you get your horoscope read when you say
a bunch of vague [ __ ] believers
believers dumb people kind of people who
sit in a pulpit you know and just listen
to another human being tell stories
about three-headed [ __ ] dogs
you know the whole thing's a dog and
pony show why are their ceiling so high
they're trying to intimidate you why are
you sitting on a piece of wood huh they
can't have sofas they don't want you
lounging then once you're sitting
upright all nervous like what what's
gonna happen to me just tell me what I
need to do you know then they walk up
those stairs made out of marble right
stand up there when they preach what's
that so they can see it you can see him
now so he gonna be a little bit higher
and [ __ ] talk down to you as you sit
on your [ __ ] wooden bench with no
cushion set up straight I'm channeling a
higher power right now
all right anyway so this [ __ ] guy
writes me and he says he says it's a
stigma dude they got a website for
[ __ ] everything if I was in my prime
if I could do it over I I would be all
over the [ __ ] Internet so they have a
website okay first of all they have it
they have a website for people with STDs
which i think is a great thing you know
let's keep it in-house no awkward
conversation huh [ __ ] you know and
then you can be honest about how you got
it where'd you get yours I got mine and
[ __ ] chili where'd you get yours dude
I was in the combat zone getting blown
on a flight of stairs right I got one
[ __ ] I don't know if she [ __ ] bit
my ball bag I was into it and evidently
she had rabies on one of her in sizes
all right so they got all these
different [ __ ] websites here 10 most
bizarre dating websites I feel like I
should have Anton fig here right now to
do a little drumroll they have a website
for look-alikes people who look like
each other which i think is awesome you
know a couple of narcissists just get
together and they don't have a day you
know neither one of them has a problem
with the other person saying I need a
little me time they can have me time
together just looking at each other how
they look alike this one basically says
uh look-alike date dating website
because that's where we're all looking
for right the founder of find your
facemate calm says she she says that she
was inspired to build a website after
people kept telling her that she and her
ex-husband look a lot alike
it's really not a common compliment then
they had they have a website for ugly
people I swear to God
Britain's first dating agency who would
I guess Britain would have a date a
dating website for ugly people you know
it's not that people in Britain are
[ __ ] ugly it's that they the country
is the size of Michigan and you know
Americans a good-looking people because
we got everybody everybody's [ __ ]
everybody we're mulching it over you got
fresh soil over here goddamn English
people they've been [ __ ] in the same
soil for years
goddamn teeth are all [ __ ] up you want
to see the worst of him look at the
royal family is there one good-looking
person Fergie Fergie could scare a
[ __ ] pug she could she looks like I
don't know what you know if a poodle
[ __ ] Helen Keller that's what that's
[ __ ] me that's what you get you get
Fergie and look at [ __ ] look at
Prince Charles Jesus Christ you know why
his wife was 20 years younger than him
because that's how much further along he
had to be intellectually to talk a
pretty [ __ ] pretty woman into bed
even with a goddamn castle
Prince William I mean they just knocked
that tee that just horrific Harry with
those beady little eyes you know he
looks like a like one of one of good
guys in Dillinger's gang from [ __ ] he
looked like they have so just been
[ __ ] each other for so goddamn long
like if you have a look at pictures of
people like from 50 years ago you know
there probably doesn't work in England
they probably look exactly the [ __ ]
same because god no it's you guys is
still [ __ ] trying to empty that keg
of DNA over there right but over here in
America people look different because we
had all these different ethnicities came
in and then everybody like people look
really ethnic like if you look at
pictures of Americans in like the 20s
Italian people looked Italian French
people look French you could tell what
country people were from and then by the
60s right after World War Two everybody
came back and just started [ __ ]
banging away okay the greatest
generation basically from their balls
came the douche generation known as the
baby boomers the whining crying patting
yourself on the back
Cantus most selfish self-righteous
generation we've ever [ __ ] had they
take credit for all the good [ __ ] and
completely ignore that they're all a
bunch of banker [ __ ] now driving
[ __ ] convertible BMWs right through
the 80s right right into AIG all those
[ __ ] people they all claim they're at
Woodstock and they protested the [ __ ]
war [ __ ] all of them all right this is a
night lot of generalities here
so anyways but if you notice those
people they they look different you know
I can't remember what my [ __ ] point
was I know I point was it's it's fitting
that England started ugly people calm
what is it called it's called the ugly
the ugly bug ball calm a dating website
you know it's funny the last time I said
English people were ugly you know who
they sent over is one of their
good-looking people was that chick from
the stuff from the Spice Girls you know
who in this country would just be the
real spot the Real Housewife of Orange
County with that awful facelift she
looks like a good looking Mouse that's
the best thing I'll give her all right
they got a sea captain website for sea
captain's for women who like guys who
[ __ ] wear that Ted Knight [ __ ] I
have a yacht hat they got that and we
just blow through these they got a dead
with the dating website for a mother's
single son mothers playing matchmakers
for their children as probably as old as
humanity itself you can't tell me that's
not that's not a major red flag okay if
there's some mother like the kids got
some sort of [ __ ] up relationship that
his mother's picking out the [ __ ] that
he's gonna bang for the rest of his
[ __ ] life do you think you're ever
gonna be dressed nice enough do you
think the house is ever gonna be neat
enough do you think your s'mores are
ever gonna taste as good as the wrinkled
[ __ ] that this guy came out of I don't
think they are so stay away from that
website that's my advice for the ladies
this week website number five are you
okay this one is for superheroes and
super villian villains are you lonely
looking for a special someone are you
looking are you also okay with tights
wearing crime fighters these [ __ ]
comic-book people they're a bunch of
freaks I think that that's what you
start off doing when you start off
dressing up like a superhero eventually
you get into that porn where
you want to [ __ ] a mascot dating website
for beautiful people that's a great one
I think that's great I think beautiful
people should [ __ ] each other and just
make more beautiful people you know give
the rest of us something to jerk off to
you know or maybe something to claim if
you go out and make you a million wooden
that'd be great
dating website for pot smokers tired of
smoking weed alone try joining 4/20
dating and pack that bowl for two of
course they have some super hot chick
with a flat stomach like she smokes weed
she's not smoking weed she's doing coke
that's how she keeps the [ __ ] weight
off can't have a stomach that flat when
you [ __ ] eat a whole bag of jacks
dating website for women behind bars
dating website for married people Oh GGH
every 20 seconds summons someone
somebody new joins Ashley Madison's
looking to have a discreet affair life
is short have an affair with the
trademark greeting like that on the
homepage you can't say that the Ashley
Madison agency are shy when it comes to
the fact that their dating websites
caters specifically to married people
with the roving eye there's even the
option to quickly visit a fake home
renovation website at any moment by
pressing a panic button Wow Wow and then
number 10 the drumroll from Anton fig is
a dating website for people with STDs
and it's a picture of two happy people
that they're psyched that they both have
I think I'm out of fun est the STDs
connect with singles who share your STD
that's the slogan from STD match net
whether you're living with herpes HPV or
anything else notice I think they take
to one scary one one kind of mainstream
one and then or anything else there's
something there's someone there for you
so there you go there you go people I
think I just helped to make a love
connection for a lot of you guys out
there those are all the people you know
there's somebody for people who smoke
weed how about you should have an
alcoholics one if you're sick as
somebody [ __ ] Ragan
to put down the goddamn bottle not for
for straight-up alcoholics because if
you're straight-up alcoholic right you
want to end the problem but just for
somebody with somebody who [ __ ] nags
you all the time right
you don't give a [ __ ] that you have a
beer belly all right
you live for sports and you live for
whatever seasonal ale Sam Adams puts out
all right and you want a giant glass and
you want to just suck down like [ __ ]
twenty of them and you just want to be
able to do that without somebody judging
you that'd be a great website that
really would I would enjoy that one god
damn it I miss beer I really [ __ ]
miss that [ __ ] people I'm coming up on
two hundred days you know vanity vanity
wise I'm loving it you know I'm in shape
again and uh by Jesus I was out and
[ __ ] Milwaukee and I was working the
paps theater and this theater was from
like the mid-1800s like like Duke
Ellington's band the original band
played there Liberace who's from
Wisconsin he played there all these
amazing amazing [ __ ] entertainers had
played there and I'm sitting there doing
my show in a way phenomenal by the way
I'm gonna tell you right now Milwaukee
in Detroit are now in the rotation
without a doubt I was blown away by how
many people showed up I was really
nervous when my guy booked both of those
cities I didn't know how many people
were gonna show up I've never done
stand-up in Milwaukee and I hadn't done
the Royal Oak Theatre in seven years
last time I did there I was on the rich
[ __ ] tour with the Chappelle show tour
with Charlie Murphy and Donnell Rawlings
I was the first guy out of the gate
nobody knew who I was everybody thought
I was a writer on Chappelle's Show which
I wasn't and or they thought I was from
the Detroit metro area I was just some
local white guy that they put on there
and that way you know but anyways a ton
of people [ __ ] showed up and basically
I forgot my point oh I remember I was in
Milwaukee and they had some beer that
was some local beer and I noticed it was
a bunch of people from Milwaukee sucking
them down and they were all saying how
good they are and that's one of the
things
like to do is check out the local
breweries a now man that was a [ __ ]
rough one to not be able to do that at
some point I'm gonna end this streak
though like when Brett Favre finally
decided alright [ __ ] it
well I guess he really didn't somebody
threw him on the ground like a rag doll
and he said I can't do it oh no that's
how his career ended like Cal Ripken Cal
Ripken took himself out of the lineup
I'm gonna do that at some point but
anyways let's plow ahead here let's get
let's get to some of the questions and
some of the comments from last week's
podcast somebody that some lady wrote in
I was talking about always wear a condom
and you can't believe the information
this lady sends in without anything else
she goes I'm a nurse and you can
actually still get herpes using a condom
just an FYI that's it no telling you how
you can get herpes by using how can you
get a hurt how can you get herpes using
a condom if you take a condom you unroll
that [ __ ] all the way down the
shaft of your [ __ ] get it all the way
down to the base and it doesn't break
and you never dip your dick in pass
where the [ __ ] condom is she never
rides you and nothing drips down on you
and nothing how does it what does it eat
through the rubber okay you're teasing
me here lady
you got me I'm on the hook I'm signed up
for the sequel for the love of God tell
me how the [ __ ] you can get herpes
wearing a goddamn condom that's that's
frightening they didn't say that in
health class that sounds like some [ __ ]
I never took a health class Who am I
kidding
you know what's staggering is I don't
know anything about the vagina I don't
know anything about it
somebody said cervix the other day and
they kept talking about their cervix and
I don't even know what it was and
evidently that's like the swinging
saloon door that the baby comes out
I don't know what ovaries are I aren't
there like two of them and that's they
spit out a couple of eggs I don't know
anything about them there's a tube in
there the eggs come down the tube or one
egg comes down the tube and if you don't
knock it up then it kind of just withers
up and then just to bloody mess once a
month is now it works I don't I don't
know yeah like if you're ever in an
elevator and we're stuck and you start
having a kid you're in trouble because I
don't know anything I don't know
anything when it go up out anything when
it comes to that [ __ ] I never took a
[ __ ] health class and for some reason
the amount of stuff that fascinates me
the reproductive aspects of a vagina
don't fascinate me I was just more
interested in the the clitoris and what
do I have to do on the inside to try to
make the same reaction happen other than
that I was good with the other stuff
it's kind of like me with cars you know
I can change the oil change an air
filter I can take out the radiator out
and replace the pumps but you know you
start getting in with the Pistons engine
I don't know [ __ ] I don't anything about
it taking that to somebody else I'll be
in the waiting room I would tell you
guys that I have no plans if I ever have
a kid to be in the [ __ ] delivery room
I'm not gonna go in there and get yelled
at you know having some woman break my
[ __ ] finger as I'm standing there
doing what what am i doing except adding
to the heat in the room just by my body
temperature and now I can't do anything
standing there dressed like like a
[ __ ] surgeon like I know what I don't
know anything
goddamn [ __ ] guys man just getting
talked into one [ __ ] thing after
another back in the day you stood out in
the waiting room where you belong
yeah let's bring somebody else in here
somebody else in here has germs you know
to breathe on the goddamn kid I don't
want to see it when it comes out when
it's not ready yet hose it off
slap it around make sure everything's
fine then bring it out hey are you doing
this sport Pat it on its soft head hand
out some cigars and then go up there and
wipe the sweat off my wife's brow that's
why I wanted to do it
old school evidently if you do that
you're the worst first person on the
planet I can't wait for that to swing
back kind of like with like eggs you
know when I was a kid eggs were healthy
and then all of a sudden everybody said
all you got to eat is the white stuff
you eat the yolk and then all of a
sudden that that he gives you a heart
attack and then it [ __ ] swung back
again oh wait the yolks okay that's what
I'm hoping for
it's gonna swing back again that's when
I'll have a kick when I could stand out
smoking a [ __ ] cigar you know just
sitting there with a [ __ ] cigar in my
mouth and duck on that ah ha oh yeah
what a girl good girl fire right
everybody smoked out go crawl away sorry
that's how I want to do it I know
there's a lot of women like you should
never be a parent whatever probably
shouldn't okay bill you should come back
and check out the Clinton Museum here in
Little Rock oh yeah last week I've
talked about the Reagan Library now we
had a great time said Arkansas sucks
our only bragging rights are Clinton and
Walmart and the Razorbacks SEC football
what are you talking about so the
Clinton museum has to be decked out to
overcompensate oh I see whenever you
come down I'll tell you some some more
old redneck sayings and my friends can
take you out hunting there's a funny
bone down here too that can be your
ticket so that can be your ticket little
typo there um you know a lot of people
are gonna take me up on that hunting
thing um I just got to figure out who's
not a psycho I mean that that was pretty
well written but you're also from
Arkansas I guess that's gonna be par for
the course right I don't go hunting in
Rhode Island I want the real deal
Arkansas is a good state
I wonder what do I want to shoot I want
to shoot a varmint let me start small I
don't want to shoot like a badger or a
Wolverine how about a raccoon shooter
right in its belly
possum something [ __ ] ugly uh number
three hey Bill as a woman I [ __ ] hate
to here [ __ ] oh wait a minute
I'm socially doing my catchphrases this
week people gave me some catch
let me try out a couple these
catchphrases you guys tell me if you
like them or not where the [ __ ] are they
alright instead of saying get er done
you could say got a Prius comically
insane
that's a catchphrase ginger and loving
it
securing my perimeter you know what that
could be the name of a special in the
late 80s if I was already a dad and I
was talking about having a man cave if I
could have come out with that before Tim
Allen came out with that pegboard and
did tool time I think I think I could
have made a zillion I don't read no
research necessary some of these are
actually doable oh if I finish the joke
after every joke I could go ah ginger
how would you guys like that he's a
[ __ ] horrific these are all and your
career catchphrases you just got bill
burned all right I'm gonna puke if I
read any more of these um all right
let's plow ahead here bill is a woman I
[ __ ] hate to hear [ __ ] complain
about being stay-at-home a stay-at-home
mom are you kidding me it'll be the
greatest gig ever I get to garden cook
go shopping watch Netflix all day but
mostly I can't believe this is written
by a woman but mostly not have to get up
and work at 7:00 a.m. every [ __ ] day
and work with a bunch of [ __ ] that I
can't stand
even the goddamn gym has a babysitter to
watch your spawn while you work out
great point then you go meet your
girlfriends for three-martini lunch then
run by Whole Foods foods in the liquor
store and go home and fix a gin and
tonic while you get dinner ready and
then give your man some hot steamy sex
when he gets home is it that hard to
push a baby carriage around and then let
that thing suck on your tip every once
in a while no it can't be I am NOT a mom
but I have a dog that's hilarious I was
gonna say that sounds like a guy I can't
believe a woman wrote this I just
completely agree with you on this
subject quit whining and learn too and
learn how to keep your legs shut if you
can't handle it anyways I love the
podcast thanks for doing it come to
Louisiana soon please I'm planning on it
in the fall
for an LSU game so there you go ladies
that's coming from one of y'all a
sellout you might say all right let's
get to advice here and then I got to
wrap this [ __ ] up really quickly uh wait
can you please keep track with it but uh
oh by the way you guys why don't you
guys vote on the on your catchphrase and
I'll say it once next week when I do the
whatever funny joke you want me to say
got a Prius like get er done got a Prius
do you like that do you want me to say
ginger and loving it securing my
perimeter or what was the last one
ah ginger vote on the mmm podcast.com I
could have sold those a lot better I
know I always promise my web guy that
I'm gonna sell this [ __ ] better and I
just you know it is this podcast to
stream-of-consciousness so if I try and
plan [ __ ] it ends up not being funny
let's get to the advice here but please
go there and please go to the mmm
podcast calm check out the YouTube
videos for the week if you want to email
me questions please send it at something
some [ __ ] I don't know what the hell it
is
what is the email it's on the mmm
podcast calm the [ __ ] is Jesus Christ
why do I try why do I my web guy right
now is just throwing his hands up in the
[ __ ] air and that's what he's saying
why do I try to help this guy this is
pointless
thank God for the donation button
anyways advice for the week I haven't
read any of these whatever I flew today
people go [ __ ] yourselves I haven't read
any of these so let me let me blow
through this it by advice you know what
I should have done I should have got a
joke book and just read bad jokes and
then then tried out the [ __ ]
catchphrases that's what I should have
done goddamnit
all right advice bill since you've
you've given great advice on
relationships in the past morning if you
can do it for me I've been with this
girl this lady of mine for years and
we're planning on getting married oh
geez we're both only 20 years old I'm a
college dropout since I'm certainly a
more blue-collar individual she is going
to college too
with children we both work full-time
jobs mind being the nightshift
in a warehouse selecting orders to go to
individual stores stressful and
physically challenging
here's being her as being a
phone-answering day job from 8 to 5
working with customers in a graphic
design shop boring and easy okay
he's defined his job is stressful and
physically challenging and her job is
boring and easy
never underestimate how tedious a boring
job can be I'd rather do your job
walking around breaking balls look at
his [ __ ] shirt dude [ __ ] quit
drive-by on the [ __ ] forklift right
guys start a softball league you have a
great time rather than sitting there
having your ass fall asleep in a cubicle
listen to the people [ __ ] cuz they
can't figure out how to work their set
it and forget it
grass is always greener my friend why
don't I shut my [ __ ] pie hole and
read the rest of this alright since we
started dating she seemed to do
everything to keep me interested make me
breakfast in the mornings on some on
some days go to concerts with me when
she didn't necessarily like the music
the whole works but I've noticed that
she without she's without question just
been lacking in the care department she
just sits and watches TV every night and
eats and complains about gaining weight
I come home in the morning to do dirty
dishes to do the dirty dishes that piled
up in the sink from her having friends
over while I'm at work for the night and
get yelled at for not cleaning them well
when I saw them sitting there but I had
no part in making them dirty dude what
the [ __ ] you can't have that she leaves
clothes laying around every room in the
house and that's not even how she is
with me
she has seemed to develop some kind of
self righteousness where everything that
she wear everything that she yeah dude
you I've really gotta proofread these
people with so many spelling to take
mistakes she has seemed to develop some
kind of self righteousness where
everything that she says throughout the
day should be my main concern and I
should go out of my way to make her life
easier I do her college homework I take
care of the $2,000
dog I bought for her I work on a car
when when she nearly runs the damn
wheels off the thing and I do chores for
her family she volunteers me for dude
she has your balls in a little debt you
know that little engagement ring you
bought her
if you bother yet your balls are in
there too the next part is the icing on
the cake she goes as far as to dictate
what time I have to go to bed and wake
up in the morning eat evening since I
work at nights what what I can and can't
spend money on who I can hang out with
what days I can see friends and require
me to call her every time I arrive at
work and text her in the middle of the
night when I get off work and request
her and I requested to do nothing
outside of what she does on her day to
day routine to sum all that up I feel
like she's forcing me into a cookie mold
guy when I actually let her make her own
decisions like some strange thing called
an adult all right I want to stop right
here dude cuz this is just gonna be more
[ __ ] misery all right this is this is
what I've said this before on the
podcast you have to I don't give a [ __ ]
how good the woman is that you're with
you really have to be careful because
all this [ __ ] you see on TV where women
are just constantly there's all this
[ __ ] information out there about how
guys are [ __ ] to women there's just
reams of it and there needs to be
because guys are [ __ ] to women so
women I think are more aware or at least
they should be more aware because they
got all these [ __ ] goddamn shows with
either and from one to four [ __ ]
sitting around bitching about guys and
all this [ __ ] that we do but there's no
show on TV where you have four guys just
sitting around a coffee table you know
drinking some hot cocoa with some
pillows and wearing sweaters and their
favorite shoes talking about you know
not losing yourself in a relationship
that's what you've done here all this
[ __ ] that she's doing is your fault
okay and what's great about being a guy
is you can blame the victim which is why
we're better problem solvers all right
this is your fault
this is all on you you
don't like any of this [ __ ] you have to
sit down and talk to her okay you you
you're not required to call her you can
go to bed when you [ __ ] want to go to
bed and you can just sit there and tell
it you did those dishes you clean it up
okay now here's the point this is the
key with this is what you got to do you
can't be mean there's no reason to be
mean here there's no reason to yell
there's no reason to be angry okay all
three of those things is what she wants
you to do because the because she knows
she's gonna know she's [ __ ] wrong if
you if you if you made the dishes dirty
and every day you're telling me to clean
him up you treat me like I'm [ __ ]
Alice on the goddamn Brady Bunch
everybody knows that that's [ __ ]
wrong
so what women do when they're [ __ ]
wrong is they try to make the argument
about something else all right so she's
gonna do that anyways so but you're
gonna make it easy if you're angry and
you yell at her and you call her [ __ ]
names so what you gotta do is you gotta
you got to keep keep your [ __ ] cool
that's what you got to do keep your
[ __ ] cool and say listen I worked all
night I don't think it's fair that you
tell me to come home and I have to do
these dishes when you made these dishes
dirty yourself I don't think it's fair
to me to come home in the morning and
have a sink full of dirty dishes that
not only you you and your friends made
dirty that's unacceptable to me that you
want me to wash those that's
unacceptable I'm not doing it you have
to wash those I'll wash my dirty dishes
I'm not doing that all right and then
then let her flip out let her pout let
her slam the [ __ ] cabinets let her
not [ __ ] you just don't back down rub
one out who gives a [ __ ] it's just an
urge you've already banged her you're
not missing anything who gives a [ __ ]
but don't get angry all right and then
just do do to her what she did to you
just just reclaim that territory you're
not doing that you're not doing that
anymore
all right start with the [ __ ] dishes
and then start with this I not in you
know you can actually tag that argument
and just say another one on this topic
of discussing things I'm going to go to
bed when I
want to go to bed I just it makes me
feel like a child when you tell them you
wanted to go to bed I know when to go to
bed alright now that I've aired to
complaints how about you give me a
couple of you got anything you want to
say to me and just stay cool then when
she hits you with some [ __ ] if you don't
like it tell her you know I was gonna
say - go [ __ ] yourself - you know I
don't know what whatever you know what
[ __ ] that last advice just go with the
dish's thing first it's unacceptable
that's it if you bring up something else
then you then it looks like you have all
this resentful [ __ ] and then she'll try
and spin it like well if you're feeling
all this why didn't you [ __ ] say
anything cuz you're a [ __ ] that's what's
gonna happen and then you're gonna lose
the argument and then next thing you
know to make up for it you're not gonna
be getting any [ __ ] from her and you
gonna be doing a whole sink full of
[ __ ] dishes that you didn't dirty
alright moving on but Sir you have all
the power there just keep your [ __ ]
cool alright next one then I got to wrap
this up this podcast is getting way too
[ __ ] long lately subject whose dick
do I have to suck to be a stay-at-home
mom bill Jesus here's another one bill
I've been with my girlfriend for a year
and a half now I love her to death we
have a fundamental problem I'm a sports
nut i watch every single Bills game in
almost every Sabres game I played high
school hockey college hockey and now
that I'm in the real world beer league
hockey twice a week my girlfriend who
has a good family life with both parents
grew up with an older brother that
played hockey with in with an entire
family that is just as ridiculous of
sports fans as I am she is a supe super
girly girl that never got into it and
since she was dragged to all of her
brother's hockey's games and hated it
she now absolutely hates sports and any
kinds of sports viewing activity alright
that's understandable this is causing an
unbelievable amount of friction lately
now that the honeymoon stage of our
relationship is over
she used to come I used to come along to
my hockey games come with me to my Super
Bowl parties and group outings at sports
bars on Sundays during the football game
now she absolutely refuses to do
anything related to sports whatsoever I
wouldn't really care that much but I
hang out with a ton of other couples and
I'm always alone now whenever I want to
watch a game bill you're a sports fan
it's a lot more fun to watch a game with
other Buffalo fans than to watch to
watch it alone
Oh God my brains tired I'm sorry guys
huh who was there to hear all that [ __ ]
you spew at the TV when you're watching
it alone nobody in my family I hate
sports you know she likes going to
basketball games she likes going to
football games and looking at the field
and then she's not into it so I you know
all right dude I already know where
you're going with this I love this girl
he says I want to work with it we are a
perfect fit every other after I talked
to her about the sports thing is really
becoming increasingly a big deal but she
would not budge on this whole sports
vendetta what does a sports fan do when
he finds himself in this situation all
right well this is what you got to do
this is the great thing okay when you're
in a relationship you do have to have
areas that you're into and the other
person isn't so you can get the [ __ ]
away from each other
absence makes the heart fonder all right
so what I would do right now is you're
basically doing to her what her family
already did which is you're not in as
bad but you're trying to force her into
this [ __ ] she doesn't want to do it she
wants to have her own life so let her
have her own life all right and you do
you [ __ ] sports thing all right and
she does her thing you do your thing and
then when there's a big game coming up
you got to do something that's gonna
make it fun for her either agree to do
some other activity with her if she
comes to the sports thing or you can
[ __ ] turn it into like a date night
thing as gay as that sounds you just
have it built around rather than some
awful [ __ ] romantic comedy movie you
have it built around the sabers game you
got to do something to make it fun for
her but right now you know what she
needs to do
she needs to detox from sports you just
did don't force it on her and just find
some other activity you guys like doing
going to the gym or some other [ __ ]
looking at the [ __ ] ducks I don't
know what find something you guys can do
together and then you watch your sports
and she goes and goes to her needlepoint
[ __ ] class whatever the hell she
wants to do maybe that's what you do I
can tell you right now all your buddies
whose broads are going to them with the
[ __ ] games eventually are gonna be
envious of the fact that you can go to a
goddamn
sports bar by yourself and they don't
have their ball and chain cuz eventually
most of their relationships are gonna
suck and they're gonna want to get a
divorce and they're just gonna be
miserable you know and then they won't
communicate and they'll gradually keep
getting fatter and fatter because
they're just gonna be drowning
themselves in appetizers and beers
that's basically what's gonna happen so
you actually have a decent situation I'm
a total sports nut Nia hates sports she
doesn't give a [ __ ] so when she watches
reality TV I go out and do stand-up and
when I watch sports she goes out works
out or goes out and [ __ ] it goes
hangs with the friends or goes in the
other room that's it and I watch it with
my dog and it's worked out so there you
go
and I think that's it i think that's the
podcast for this week I got a couple
YouTube videos how they make the ice
rink they got a couple of good videos
like this this will send you to some
links how to make a backyard ice rink
which is something I've always dreamed
of doing you know back in the day when I
thought I was gonna be a dad and have
four [ __ ] kids you know three boys
and a girl I wouldn't I wouldn't let the
girl play hockey though you know what I
mean I wouldn't let him do that you know
I just wouldn't it's just too you know
if I had a girl I got side-centered like
- how to make a grilled cheese sandwich
like class you know I really want to
bring back the America that I've read
about you know the chauvinistic I'm
[ __ ] with you guys
here's another one eating fish alive I
don't know what this one is eating fish
alive is this something about Asia
okay there is a fish on a plate and it
looks like it's waving like please
please we'll be back in the water on
this chopsticks
what a surprise those little dishes that
you put the thing that is the [ __ ]
worst thing I've ever seen
stab it with the [ __ ] stick you
[ __ ]
they just eaten the ginger around it you
know what what is with the continent of
Asia when it comes to animals that you
know I know we do cruel [ __ ] in this
country but if they just [ __ ] go
above and beyond do you guys ever see
that movie The Cove I never had the
balls to watch it it's basically about
Japanese people Club and dolphins to
death not all of them but just some
people I'm not sure saying that Asia is
a bad place you know look at us with our
guns there's a lot of [ __ ] that we do
that's probably [ __ ] stupid but how
do you how do you do that [ __ ] thing
is just sitting there moving it's Finn I
don't know by the way somebody sent me
an email that went above and beyond this
is some extra time here on the podcast
that this one is beyond my advice by the
way this guy basically sent me an email
he said I was good friends with us this
was female we've known each other since
my freshman year at the University of
blah blah blah in the year 2000 we keep
in contact she's like my kids sister I
thought this was gonna be like she's
like my kid sister but he really had
like a crush on her it's funny but it
isn't goes takes a total left turn he
says we all keep in contact my whole
crew of college friends we all keep in
contact and we meet as much as possible
the girl who is my kids sister she went
to the Peace Corps in 2008 and she got a
boyfriend who left the Peace Corps early
to be with her and this guy says I don't
like this guy to put it tersely he's
he's done nothing to warrant any
antagonism but he's just never set well
with me I've kept it to myself because
they love quote each other and he has
never set a foot wrong with me or even
my friends in fact he is overly
attentive to her
I have never seen my kids sister friend
they're so attached to her bow to a
boyfriend last holiday we all got
together and some of us noticed a mark
changed in my girlfriend my I'm trying
not to name her name let's just call her
Lisa Lisa's demeanor she's usually very
bright bubbly and vivacious girl a type
of girl who wasn't the prettiest in the
room but could catch any man's attention
with her Jam and personality now she has
an insecure negative mopey introverted
attitude she marked it down to her she
tried to say it was her graduate school
stress but this was but she was this way
for an entire week this past Sunday
another friend in the group will call
her Suzy and I were arranging plans and
late-may to go to Mobe I don't know what
the [ __ ] that is and they stated that
Lisa and her boyfriend might not go then
the bomb came she let it slip that the
real reason her boyfriend left the Peace
Corps was because he was a teacher and
beat up a six-year-old kid in school he
didn't leave the Peace Corps because of
Lisa he left because he was asked to
leave
Lisa specifically told the rest not to
mention it because of how I owe to me
because I would react since the incident
was a misunderstanding I lived with an
abusive father and she know the story
would put him in a bad light and I
realized immediately why I didn't like
this dude why this douche didn't sit
well with me he reminded me of my father
so goes on to continue it gets really
dark here well basically they think that
this guy thinks that she's being
physically abused or whatever dude this
is a dr. Drew question all right this is
my advice call dr. Drew call Loveline he
will know exactly what the [ __ ] to do if
not to send you in the right direction
the name of the show is love line you
can find it the guy's super famous I
don't have the link here but yeah guys
don't don't don't ask me questions like
that because that is I'll ask the silly
ones I like sports and she doesn't like
but that is above and beyond
you know this podcast and my ability to
answer questions like that I
feel [ __ ] horrific you know I mean I
say a lot of [ __ ] horrific [ __ ] about
women on here but I'm obviously just
[ __ ] around this is all comedy and
stuff like I have no idea how I would
approach that but uh you know I all I
can tell you is that I've known somebody
that was in a situation like that and
it's hard when they're in the denial and
protecting their douche of a [ __ ]
boyfriend and they won't [ __ ] own up
to it it's it's kind of an impossible
situation until they finally admit that
they got a [ __ ] problem so I don't
know it's above and beyond me what a
[ __ ] up way to end the podcast but I
wanted to at least try to send this guy
in the right direction because that's uh
was just a creepy [ __ ] email so uh
yeah so don't send me the creepy emails
everybody I'm flattered that someone
would think that I could possibly know
what the [ __ ] to do they're calling the
love line for the serious ones the silly
stupid ones you know I love her brother
clam stinks you know those are the ones
for me so that's the podcast for this
week I hope you guys enjoyed it we're
gonna have another podcast this week I'm
gonna put it up possibly Tuesday or
Wednesday I'll announce it on the mmm
podcast this week where I actually I'll
put it up on Wednesday let's have it
defined Wednesday will be a special
edition of the Monday morning podcast
and I'll have special guests Robert
Kelley and Joe DeRosa and we're gonna be
talking about a film in the Tribeca Film
Festival the film called cheap we're
gonna talk about how we all know each
other we're gonna tell old stories we're
gonna break each other balls probably
trash each other and it might hurt our
friendships but it's gonna be hilarious
to you guys I hope you enjoy it go [ __ ]
yourselves have a great week and I
actually know I'll talk to you on
Wednesday
see
yourselves into
you say you
[Music]
and this goes
and
[Music]
change
if you do
what good is that
so you've painted yourself into a car
[Music]
and you
most like a soldier
into war caught between
[Music]
no he was fired